bioshock is a fantastic series and it's
due to how much these games affected me
that i wanted to talk about them all
with you this video is actually three
separate parts turned into a much larger
project with each video being made with
the sole intention of not only retelling
the story of these games but to also
allow me to give my thoughts on their
stories along the way if you're new here
then this is the perfect place to watch
all three videos but even if you've seen
them already there is an added section
at the end where we discuss the two
novels released during the game's life
cycle with all of that out of the way
though welcome to the bioshock series
story retrospective let's get started
bioshock 1 has one of the most genius
stories i have ever seen its central
plot is brilliant and the attention to
detail when it came to its setting in
world building is arguably a masterpiece
just on its own today i want to look
back on bioshock's story and uncover
what really made this one of the best
games of all time despite it being 14
years old as always spoiler warning
ahead for the whole story of bioshock
and with that let's get started as
always we need to start at the prologue
but for bioshock we need to go back even
further that title bioshock it's such a
bizarre word when you think about it
many games have a very distinct title
with weird meanings but at least i could
tell you what the words mean cyberpunk
2077 is a game with a cyberpunk art
style that's set in the year 2077. a
game like dragon age is a bit tricky is
i've never played dragon age before so
while its title as a whole makes no
sense to me i can at least understand
what the individual words mean dragon
age and origins and maybe draw some
conclusions about the game but what is a
bioshock i like many might think it's a
homage to system shock 2 which was
irrational games first project but
furthermore it could also be a shortened
version of biological shock which in the
context of the game makes sense given
how adam ruined this society and how our
protagonist acts throughout the game but
we haven't gotten there yet so i'll
return to this in a moment as we start
the game the player needs certain
questions answered in order to feel
invested in the story who are we how did
we get here and does the story make
sense bioshock creates a sort of meta
narrative based around these answers but
once again more on that at the end of
the video our first interaction with the
game is a cutscene and bioshock wastes
no time getting right into the action as
the plane were traveling on crashes in
the middle of the atlantic ocean we
awake amongst the wreckage and need to
find land the only place within eyesight
is a giant lighthouse next to us i've
always seen this lighthouse as a beacon
of light in a dark time although it's a
bit more literal in this case as the
only light we can see is the moon the
burning plane and this lighthouse as we
enter the door shuts behind us and we
see a giant statue of a man with the
phrase no gods or kings only man written
on a banner while it's confusing as is
this confusion should actually start
earlier why is there a lighthouse in the
middle of the atlantic ocean even if we
were to ignore that why isn't there
people in the lighthouse there's so much
wrong with all of this and while that
does sound like a criticism i actually
find it to be a wonderful decision as
it's making the player question
everything they see it's also the start
of many mysteries this game will tease
to the player which causes them to
become more invested in the world around
them in an attempt to find out more as
we head down the stairs we see three
plaques with the words art industry and
science written on them while a violin
cover of bobby darren's beyond the sea
accompanies us in the bathysphere what's
important to remember is why we're going
in this submarine we're in the middle of
the ocean and it's the 60s even if
others had survived that plane crash who
will be going to call for help our only
option is this bathysphere as it's
either this or swimming at night in the
atlantic ocean and i'll take my chances
we presumably descend deeper into the
lighthouse while a message plays from
andrew ryan someone who looks oddly
similar to the statue upstairs bioshock
has many memorable moments and this will
be one of three key moments throughout
the entire game i have rejected those
answers
instead
i chose something different i chose the
impossible
i chose
rapture
[Music]
rapture might be my favorite setting in
any video game ever made not just the
idea but the reasoning behind it is
brilliant the fact that a city not only
exists at the bottom of the sea but also
functions at the bottom of the sea is
something that has never been done
before andrew ryan also says that
rapture was made for those who do not
fear censors or morality it's a judgment
free place but not in the sense of
people getting along and being happy
together but a place that allowed those
who wanted more to get more injured ryan
says that the surface was constrained by
laws and ethics but rapture was no such
place and it's because of this ideology
that allowed rapture to blossom into
what we see now a bustling city under
the sea completely shut away from
society at least that's what it seems
like until we actually enter rapture our
first encounter with the city is a very
grim one as we're going to be introduced
to a man named johnny until we get to
see him sliced open right in front of us
we then meet with johnny's killer who
screams at us before attempting to open
the bathysphere it's possible that her
anger is the same as the people who used
to be here as there are signs everywhere
saying things like ryan doesn't own us
let us leave and the rapture is dead
earlier i talked about a light that
shines in the darkness when i brought up
the lighthouse atlas is like the
lighthouse but in a more metaphorical
sense as atlas saves us from this person
who is trying to kill us his charming
demeanor and attitude makes him
instantly likable and that is further
reinforced by his own actions as once
again he's trying to save us we push
further and are able to arm ourselves
with a wrench we can take a couple
practice swings to test out our new
weapon but we can also get a look at
these splicers atlas was talking about
as they aren't alien creatures but they
don't look human anymore everything
seems to be going smoothly so far given
the circumstances until we see the
gatherer's guarded vending machine
[Applause]
hold on and everything will be fine
[Applause]
look mr bubbles it's an angel
i can see light coming from his belly
wait a minute he's still breathing
it's all right
i know he'll be an angel soon
i can't explain to you how genuinely
terrifying this was when i first played
the game currently we don't understand
what a big daddy or a little sister is
just yet so seeing a tiny child with a
syringe as big as she is walking with a
moving scuba suit is probably the most
terrifying thing you'll ever see we also
discover that we can now cast
electricity through our hands which is
just another bizarre and crazy thing
that rapture has we also get a look at a
concept that is shown throughout rapture
and it's how the world continues to
reinforce that you're underwater it's
not enough just to have a few windows
that show the sea but the effects that
the outside environment can have on
rapture such as the plane wing crashing
into the tunnel causing all the water to
flood inside there are even smaller
instances of this such as the water
falling from the ceiling or just puddles
of water in places where it shouldn't be
bioshock also shows other problems that
rapture can have like a lack of
electricity or when this elevator falls
and instead of just being a cool scene
to ramp up the destruction we can
actually see someone walk out of it
while on fire it makes rapture seem real
as it showcases how a place like this
can have problems but also what problems
a place like this may face like water
damage and poor infrastructure if you
want to go even further than this this
is also the first showcase of how the
splicers interact inside the game as
this female spicer is trying to sing a
lullaby to her baby despite it being
quite the frightening tale she's talking
about how her baby is going to be sold
by the pound once her dad is gone and
how she'll be alone when her parents are
both dead except it seems like she's
losing her mind as she's struggling to
figure out why her baby doesn't feel the
same anymore until we realize her baby's
actually a pistol atlas was also
listening in on this lullaby as he says
that it was the plasmids that caused all
the chaos there's even an audio log not
even a couple minutes later that
captures one of the moments of rapture's
downfall here's a toast to diane
mcclintock
silliest girl in rapture
silly enough to fall in love with andrew
ryan
silly
[Applause]
oh god
what's happening
it seems that an explosion went off
during the new year's eve party
presumably right where we're standing
which killed numerous people we don't
know why but if we're to believe atlas
plasmids caused it in some way later we
get to see the little sister and big
daddy again and are able to observe them
without the fear of being stabbed and
it's quite the brutal scene it shows the
dynamic relationship between the two and
also the importance of the little sister
and the strength of the big daddies we
learn that the little sisters gather at
them while the big daddies protect them
from people who want to harm them it's
also assumed that people might want to
harm the little sister because of the
atom that she carries after some
fighting we make it to the end of the
intro where andrew ryan appears and
notices that we've invaded his city he
asks for a part of the cia or kgb as he
probably assumes that the only people
capable of finding and infiltrating his
great city would be the government and
he also thinks that the government
either wants to put an end to his city
or nationalize it to things he'll never
let happen despite being just a voice
for a majority of the game it's his
personality and the power in his voice
that makes him feel like a threat and
i've always liked how impressive the
voice acting was for him of course we
have to escape his ambush and arrive at
the medical pavilion ending the tutorial
bioshock's intro is pretty much perfect
we get a cohesive set of circumstances
that show how our character made it to
rapture and then get introduced to what
rapture looks like how its inhabitants
interact with the city and a few pieces
of information for the player to think
about like plasmids adam big daddies
little sisters and the downfall of
rapture there is even a ton of things we
still don't know yet like who we are who
atlas is and how the plane crashed and
while i do wish more backstory was given
on this once you beat the game you
realize it's impossible to talk about
right now there was so much mystery with
bioshock from its setting to its
characters to even the actual plot that
it makes you want to learn more and
while this information and mystery can
be considered overwhelming when shown
all at once these mechanics characters
and locations are everywhere so it's
hard not to remember them and it also
gives the player something to go off of
instead of being left in the dark all
game it's also been like 15 minutes
since we started the game so it's not
like it's been four hours of game time
without any answers we're just getting
started so having a bit of mystery is
perfectly fine this early in the game
and the way this is pulled off in
bioshock is expertly done from here
things start to become harder to talk
about as bioshock's main world building
device is the audio logs we find
scattered around the map there is a
common critique amongst gamers that it's
unimersive when there are audio logs or
recordings scattered throughout the
world as it makes no sense that this
many people would be using them when
talking about the most mundane of topics
and while i definitely agree with this
sentiment i've always just chalked it up
to a limitation of game design
especially in the case of bioshock where
there are no npcs the player can talk to
to learn about rapture so all their
information has to be from the audio
logs thankfully there is a ton of them
in this game and are extremely easy to
find as they glow and are more often
than not found in areas you'll be
traveling through anyway these provide
lots of context to rapture's downfall
and explain a lot of what's going on
around the city except they are
everywhere throughout the game and not
placed in the most linear fashion for
example we see these ghostly apparitions
throughout the game but it isn't until
we get to arcadia roughly three or so
hours into the game where we finally
learn why we can see ghosts i have no
problem with the way these audio logs
are structured it just becomes a little
harder to explain when making a video
about it so for now we'll just be going
in the order the game intended and
occasionally go off the beaten path to
discuss some other aspects of the game
like right now as it's a perfect time to
talk about rapture itself as i said
before it wasn't just the scenery of the
city that made me love rapture but it's
what it represents that intrigued me
just like the title of the game we need
to address the main name of the city
rapture by definition is a feeling of
intense pleasure or joy but it's also a
theological belief within christianity
assuming my research is correct it's an
event that would be the end of times
where those who are faithful christians
whether alive or dead will be taken
above the clouds to meet the lord all
those who are not faithful will not be
taken up thus are condemned to whatever
destruction the rapture brings rapture
the city relates to this as you can
infer that this place above the clouds
would be considered a paradise for all
christians so rapture is a place for
those who want to experience a paradise
away from the mainland as ryan said it's
for the artist who doesn't fear
censorship or the scientist who isn't
bound by a petty morality rapture allows
the creativity of the mind to be the
only limit within its walls and this is
why the city of rapture had so many
scientific breakthroughs the residents
of rapture never needed to worry about
whether or not what they were doing was
unethical dangerous or controversial as
they were given complete freedom rapture
essentially went through a never-ending
golden age of technological advancement
people were able to conjure elements
through their hands and were able to
have not just their facial features
reconstructed but their entire gender
and even their race changed as well even
though it all went to [ __ ] eventually
just the concept of rapture is genius
it's incredibly thorough and really
highlights the stellar writing of this
game as the biggest question that comes
to mind is why build a city in the ocean
and yet the devs managed to not only
give an answer to this question but
actually make it quite believable
continuing where we left off we had just
escaped andrew ryan's ambush and have
made it to the medical pavilion
according to atlas this is the direction
we have to head in if we're to save his
family i said earlier how bioshock's
intro showcases how some of the splicers
interact with the city and while in that
case it was just a small example this
concept gets brought up again but with
more depth added to it from the moment
we enter the pavilion we see signs and
posters of a dr steinman he's the
overseer of the medical pavilion and is
also a very accomplished surgeon one
thing you'll notice about bioshock is
how all the name characters have a story
about them each character has a
backstory and a reason for coming to
rapture and all their stories tie into
the overarching story of rapture each
area also has a distinct look to them
and a reason for being in the city and
both the levels and characters within
them all tie into rapture in some way
which we uncover from the audio logs dr
steinmann performed cosmetic surgery on
the people of rapture but due to the
circumstances of the city he too became
corrupt due to rapture being a place
where people can show their truest forms
and are able to push the boundaries of
their studies dr steinman would use this
time to perfect his craft everything was
going well until the discovery of adam
as this sparked an idea in steinman's
head as he thought this was a perfect
opportunity to revolutionize the
industry hoping that with this new
technology surgeons could sculpt any
kind of flesh with ease but this of
course led him down a darker path see
steinman was a perfectionist and of
course when you're a perfectionist your
standards are incredibly high but adam
managed to push these even further
adam presents new problems for the
professional
as your tools improve so do your
standards there was a time
i was happy enough to take off a water
too or turn a real circus freak into
something you can show in the daylight
but
that was then
when we took what we got but with adam
the flash becomes clay
what excuse do we have not to
sculpt and sculpt and sculpt until the
job is done
dr steinman didn't go crazy just because
of adam it was a combination of adam
rapture and his inability to let the
smallest problem go he would change
things that patients didn't want and
given that he's a professional in his
line of work he used this to reinforce
his actions why argue with the
professional after all they know all
there is to know steinman lost control
and began working on anyone he wanted
even if they weren't a patient of his
his final decline is how we see him in
game he moved away from the faces of his
patients to their whole physique
claiming that this one was too fat or
this one's too tall or that this one is
too symmetrical he ended up losing his
mind when he was introduced to adam he
wasn't an addict to the drug but an
addict to his work he saw the potential
of adam and his first thought was how
far can he go without thinking how far
should he go this shows that adam and
even the policies of rapture affected so
many of its city's residents and due to
their different fields of study and
different levels of wealth and social
status we're able to see how it affects
everyone differently this style of
storytelling is flat out genius it makes
you want to go to the next area and
uncover what the level is about what it
provides the city of rapture and how its
unique setting caused its unique
downfall no game has ever gotten me to
care this much about one small level and
i find that in itself very impressive
after we have dealt with dr steinman we
enter the second key moment of bioshock
as we approach this hallway we see a big
daddy get thrown through the wall this
is the first time we have not only seen
a big daddy up close besides the
cutscene from earlier but we actually
see one defeated so it must be a really
tough opponent who brought him down
except it's just another splicer even
though i've always found this almost
impossible to happen that's not the
point of the scene as now that the big
daddy is dead the little sister is alone
the splicer takes this opportunity to
grab the little sister so he can take
her at him but a mysterious woman shoots
him before he can do that i'll bring her
up in a moment but right now she and
atlas give us a choice these little
sisters contain adam the core foundation
of rapture and if we can get more we can
buy more plasmids and tonics to get
stronger but we're also doing so at the
cost of potentially killing her rescuing
a little sister will net us 80 adam but
she lives harvesting her will give us
160 but she dies it's a case of morality
are you willing to sacrifice the life of
a little girl for the benefit of your
own especially when you uncover their
origins it makes the choice even more
important the little sisters were a
creation of tenenbaum the woman from
earlier after discovering a sea slug
that was able to cure the wounds of a
smuggler when it bit him after some
research on the slug she discovered what
caused this anomaly and dubbed the
substance atom she also discovered that
had the ability to splice people's dna
giving them the opportunity to
essentially have superpowers leading to
the creation of plasmids the problem
with adam is that on its own there
wasn't enough to change anything but
tenenbaum found a way to create adam
inside people's bodies but once again
this also failed as it wasn't enough the
only test that worked was with young
girls which was the start of the little
sisters another problem arose is there
wasn't enough girls to go around as who
would willingly subject their daughters
to this experiment so fontaine can
spread with tenenbaum to create an
orphanage that would be used as a front
to exploit the children and specifically
take the girls to use them as hosts for
adam despite how creepy they may look
when you rescue them you discover that
they are just in fact little girls not
some mutant creature but a living
breathing human she with the assistance
of a dr shu chong who we'll get to in a
moment subjected the little girls to
mental conditioning so they can become
valuable hosts so she cares enough about
the little sisters that when someone
else hurts them she'll defend them but
when she hurts them it's okay her logic
is clearly flawed and there is a reason
for that as she feels awful about what
she did but the majority of the audio
logs we find say the opposite this makes
tenenbaum a hard person to trust which
not only reinforces the game's concept
of morality when it comes to the little
sisters but also strengthens the
relationship between you and atlas it's
a great idea on paper but horribly
executed in game sadly according to
tenenbaum if we save enough of her
little one she'll give us a reward this
is in the form of a present near the
plasmid vending machines that has atom a
plasmid and some other items like ammo
and eve the number of atom is consistent
every time so if we're to compare the
two we find out that every three little
sisters rescued gives us 440 atom
assuming you collect the present and 480
if we harvest all of them if the player
were to rescue harvest all 21 little
sisters they will get either 3 000 80
atom or
3360 atom respectively this is already a
problem on its own but they continue to
add more items for the player easily
making rescuing the best option without
even thinking about the morality of the
situation a 280 atom difference in the
grand scheme of things is really not
that big of a deal especially when you
get to the end of the game when you can
upgrade your plasmids that run as high
as 180 atom now maybe i play the game
differently than others but i never
needed many plasmids during my
playthrough i wasn't constantly starved
of atom i just needed a few important
tonics and some go-to plasmids and that
was it you really don't need an entire
arsenal of tonics and plasmids to
complete this game unless you're doing a
sort of challenge run or something what
they should have done was kept the
rewards from the present but cut the
atom we get from the gifts and rescuing
in half going from a total of 3 360 adam
if you harvest them to 1 680 if you
choose to rescue all of them this also
cuts your survivability in half all
health and eve upgrades are 80 atoms
each buying all of them throughout the
game will set you back 1280 atom leaving
you only 400 to use on upgrades and
plasmids so it creates the situation
about whether or not you should dabble
in more health or eve or use the atom to
upgrade your plasmids this would make
saving the little sisters a lot harder
to do and force the player to actually
choose between rescuing or harvesting
them are you still willing to stick to
your morals and never harvest one no
matter how hard it gets or are you going
to cave in furthermore are you going to
justify your actions or live with the
fact that what you did is wrong if you
plan on justifying it aren't you no
better than the people who live here
like steinman who used his work as
justification for his ruthless actions
although loads of other people will meet
soon who also did evil things because
they were furthering their field of
study i'm also not the only one that
thinks these rewards should have been
handled better as the creative director
for the game even agrees yeah and we
went back and forth a lot about what the
rewards for harvesting versus saving
would be and actually i think we should
really
pushed further that the rewards for
saving
were much more much more should have
been much more meager than the rewards
for harvesting you probably have noticed
by now that we've spent a lot of time
talking about dr steinman and the little
sisters but not about the actual medical
pavilion itself and this is where
bioshock tends to suffer a bit the
medical pavilion level has 17 audio logs
the player can find and only eight of
them aren't made by dr steinman while
this sounds like a great opportunity for
the other logs to introduce more lore on
the other doctors and patients bioshock
doesn't do this the other eight audio
logs are random logs like andrew ryan
talking about the vandalism of vending
machines or dr shuchong testing out a
new plasmid you could have put these
anywhere else in the game and you
wouldn't bat an eye as they fit anywhere
since their story isn't related to a
specific area it's not a bad decision to
make these kind of audio logs but it's
clear that it makes it harder to fill
the others with more content about the
actual level it makes the medical
pavilion seem only about dr steinman and
not the other people in the pavilion
thankfully the environment does attempt
to assist them in some ways but the rest
of the level lacks in any sort of story
outside of steinmen this also isn't a
level issue but more of a whole game
issue sometimes it always feels like the
world revolves around specific key
people and never anyone else our next
level is a great example of the opposite
as neptune's bounty has no end boss well
sort of and we'll get to that regardless
there are 19 audio logs in here and
there's a very diverse cast of
characters within them as most of them
have between three to five logs each on
top of this majority of the logs add to
the level's ecosystem neptune's bounty
was used as a cover up for a man named
frank fontaine and his smuggling ring
many items inside rapture were
considered contraband as that would
disrupt everything rapture was built for
and a large majority of these audio logs
aren't about one person but the area as
a whole such as when tenanbomb
discovered that slug we talked about
earlier this links to the creation of
atom but also adds to the level itself
as this discovery was found here there's
also an audio log about a man named
sullivan who is a detective for andrew
ryan who's trying to find evidence
against fontaine his audio logs show the
steps during his case as he attempts to
interrogate a smuggler of fontaine's we
can actually find the location of where
this interrogation happened in the level
and this also relates to the level as a
whole again as this is where fontaine
does his smuggling so it would make
sense that a detective would be here
this is the weird problem with
bioshock's audio logs but i do want to
make one thing very clear i do not hate
the concept of these logs there are
great ways of providing lore and world
building to the game even if they really
shouldn't exist as we discussed earlier
plus they're audio logs not notes
meaning the player can walk around and
explore the level while listening to it
rather than sitting still and reading
text however it's very clear that there
is some favoritism and inconsistency
with these audio logs where one area
will have most of the logs be about one
character another may have it be about
the actual level and sometimes it's
neither it can make the story harder to
follow at times as events may occur
earlier than when they get explained and
can also be the opposite where something
gets explained but then is shown to the
player later with the hopes that they
remember it getting back to the actual
story neptune's bounty is the next level
we come across then as i said earlier
there is technically no boss in the
level at least bioshock's version of a
boss as peach wilkins doesn't have that
audio log treatment that many others got
like dr steinman he only gets three
audio logs throughout the game so it's
clear he wasn't intended to be a boss or
main character of an area just a
roadblock for the player to go around
this is further reinforced by him
denying us access to smuggler's hideout
and subsequently atlas's family until we
can get him a research camera i'm not
the only person to say this but from a
story and gameplay perspective this
camera is very video gamey the fact that
a camera is able to analyze genetic
material from a simple picture is a
possible stretch that i'm willing to
just barely forgive but it is in no way
entertaining to start a fight with a
camera so you can snapshot a picture of
your enemy then get back to fighting at
the end of the day it's a really small
part of the game so i tend not to dwell
on this too much the fight that follows
though has always been a blast to do as
it forces you to get creative with your
plasmids incinerate can be used to open
up more doorways which double as cover
and sources of eve and ammo furthermore
you can make this encounter much more
entertaining if you picked up the
security bullseye from earlier and don't
even get me started about new game plus
as this makes this encounter even better
peaches is a bullet sponge however and
does take numerous hits to die from
pretty much anything but it does add to
the intensity of the fight so i didn't
really mind it after somehow making it
out alive we arrive at smuggler's
hideout where the cora fontaine
smuggling ring is located despite it
being the shortest level in bioshock it
does an amazing job showing off its
environment as all these boxes we see
throughout the level are the contraband
fontaine was smuggling in we also do get
to see a flashback appear on screen when
we enter the area this isn't the first
time we've seen one and it won't be the
last but it's relevant later so we'll
leave it for now it's also here where we
finally meet up with atlas and help him
rescue his family we let atlas through
the door and we watch as he attempts to
free his family ninja ryan comes on the
radio and mocks us saying maybe you
could warn him or if only you could do
something except just stand there and
watch him die on its own it's exactly as
it sounds but i've always found this to
have a double meaning after knowing the
ending of the game but just like the
flashbacks and the tons of other things
we've talked about before today we'll
talk about that later we run down the
stairs to help atlas but he is
overwhelmed by splicers and needs to
fall back but as we approach the sub to
finish the job he started it explodes in
front of us this is a turning point for
the game atlas the man who saved us and
who we can consider to be a dear friend
of ours had just watched his family die
in front of him atlas and now the player
will want revenge for this and the only
person to enact that on is andrew ryan
that's why our next objective is to find
the bathysphere in rolling hills as this
will take us right to andrew ryan
himself our next level arcadia is
simultaneously where the middle of the
game starts and also where it starts to
plummet in regards to the story from a
gameplay perspective this is just like
the previous levels but with new
plasmids new enemies more upgrades and
different environments i thoroughly
enjoyed the gameplay when going through
these sections but it carries the levels
as there isn't much story to go off of
however i will admit that there is the
occasional audio log sprinkled in the
next few levels that is very important
to understanding the backstory of
rapture and that there is a very unique
sense of style to these places as they
all serve very unique purposes arcadia
is a literal forest of trees which is
how rapture is able to produce oxygen
despite being hundreds of feet under the
water however the majority of the audio
logs in arcadia are dedicated to one
person julie langford the creator of the
arcadia forest except she's not a main
boss like steinman in fact she helps us
which is a nice change of pace but her
audio logs don't really add much
substance one talks about her tests
regarding this lazarus device and how
she wants to test the rosa gallica
flower to see its results but she was
unable to due to a recent lockdown if
the bright colors and presentation
weren't obvious it's clear from the
audio log that these flowers will be
important later even if you didn't piece
that together she'll have you go fetch
one anyway so it doesn't matter if you
caught on or not another talks about
this cult with an arcadia called the
satorine except it's just about how they
steal her equipment and how they believe
they're touched by the gods we do get to
see this cult in the game as all the
houdini spoilers in arcadia are a part
of the group but nothing else is
developed they're just a cult with no
motivation and no real reason to exist
as from what we gather from the audio
logs they just drink human blood and
plasmids steal julie's research
materials and are avoided by many of the
people in rapture as they brutally kill
anyone who isn't a part of them the
question is though why well if the wiki
has anything to go off of it was
discovered that this cult was put into
the game very late in development and
thus the devs ran out of time to add any
proper backstory to them while i will at
least recognize that there was an
attempt to add backstory assuming that
article is true it wasn't present in the
full release thus i can only go off of
what we have in game this same sort of
storytelling though occurs all the way
up until we meet andrew ryan where there
is that lack of substance in the audio
log save for a few key logs at specific
points everything we have to do was made
by the devs to add length to the game
and extend its gameplay once again
taking everything into account i don't
mind this as the gameplay was fun and
i'll gladly take another couple hours of
it but when only looking at the story
it's clear we're being dragged along and
constantly stalled for the sake of run
time to get to andrew ryan from here we
need to get through arcadia except
andrew ryan shuts off some of the oxygen
so we need to turn it back online with
the help of julie to turn it on we need
to create the lazarus vector julie was
working on so we need to go from arcadia
to the farmer's market to grab the
materials then go back to arcadia to put
it together we then have to hold out
from a never-ending wave of splicers as
they attempt to shut down the device
after this we traveled to fort frolick
to find that bathysphere only for the
artist and serial killer sander cohen to
interrupt us after dealing with him we
make it to hephaestus a large industrial
power plant where we can go to andrew
ryan's office only for it to be locked
to turn off this electrical lock and get
into his office we need to blow up the
power plant using a literal bomb this
takes around 4 or so hours to complete
which doesn't seem like a long time
until you realize this campaign's run
time is close to 10 hours that's also
being extremely generous given the
quality of the bioshock remasters is
awful and continues to crash and this
game doesn't have any consistent auto
saves as the only trigger when you enter
a new level so assuming you get wrapped
up in gameplay and forget to save like i
did you might be losing a couple minutes
to a whole hour of progress so if
anything it's actually less than 10
hours but still it's clear that a large
portion of the game is within these
levels technically you could argue that
the first few levels do the exact same
thing as it does take quite a bit of
time to get to smuggler's hideout but
not only are these levels short as that
whole sequence takes around half the
time the levels themselves are covered
in numerous audio logs related to the
area or the main boss of said area we've
already discussed before how arcadia
does attempt to do the same but fails by
not providing enough substance the
farmer's market suffers from the exact
same fate as arcadia and hephaestus has
a couple important logs that are helpful
to understanding the downfall of rapture
but fort frolick and sandra cohen are
probably the only exception as sander
cohen is actually a really entertaining
villain and there is one extremely
important audio log that has relevance
to the end of the game sander cohen is
extremely creepy and also a bit sad at
the same time he's a poet composer
sculptor and playwright he's clearly
talented in the realm of art but he too
was subjected to the same problems many
had thanks to adam where steinman became
more infatuated with his work thanks to
adam as he attempted to erase all the
problems he had sandra cohen would use
this opportunity to also enhance his
craft he created artwork from his
victims by covering them in plaster and
setting them up in various poses it's
horrifying especially when you discover
that they're actual people as they bleed
when you hit them as i said he's creepy
and his mannerisms and speech reflect
this too but he's also quite the sad
person as his audio logs and even some
dialogue from andrew ryan point to him
seeing us as a spark he needed to keep
going the reason sandra cohen keeps us
here is that he needed help completing
his masterpiece a full four picture
display of his colleagues who betrayed
him next to a ton of bodies it's our job
to kill his colleagues and take their
pictures i do like how the pictures we
take with the camera are the actual
photos and not some preset photo the
devs had in place so nice touch when we
put the third photo in the picture frame
he freaks out claiming that we are
doubting his work in his fit of rage he
has numerous spider splicers attack us
he calms down after a while and does
apologize for the unnecessary outburst
but it's clear that he does not like
people who dislike his work by us
helping cohen and seeing his masterpiece
through to the end we can possibly give
him the strength he needed to keep going
with his artwork and convey to him that
he is indeed an excellent artist it also
seems that he may have planned to kill
andrew ryan at some point as one audio
log says that he wants to create a
requiem for him it's also during this
level where we uncover a very important
scene of jasmine jolene who we find out
as andrew bryant's mistress who's
talking about her recent pregnancy
i'm sorry mr ryan i didn't know
i didn't know fontaine had something to
do with it
what are you doing no
no don't play i love you
[Music]
that creepy doctor tenembot promised me
it wasn't gonna be a real pregnancy
they just take the egg out once mr ryan
and i had
oh i needed the money so bad
but i know mr ryan's gonna suss it out
gonna no i wasn't being careful
i'm gonna know i sold the
mr ryan's gonna be so mad at me
from what we gather it seems that andrew
ryan had discovered what occurred and
beat her to death with a pipe this
incident just like many we have
discovered today will be relevant later
but not too much later as after running
through the power plant crafting the
bomb and destroying the power we can
finally come face to face with the man
himself
the assassin has overcome my final
defense and now he's come to murder me
in the end what separates
a man
from a slave
money
power
no
a man
chooses
a slave obeys
you think you have memories
a father
a family
airplane
a crash
and then this place
was there really a family
did that airplane crash
or
was it hijacked
forced down
forced down by something less than a man
something bred to sleepwalk through life
until they are activated by a simple
phrase spoken by their kindly master
was a man sent a kill
or a slave
a man chooses
a slave obeys
come in
stop would you come
would you
kindly powerful phrase
familiar phrase
would you kindly
would you kindly get this would you
kindly find
would that kindly head to ryan's office
and kill the son of a [ __ ]
sit
would you kindly
stand
would
a man chooses
a slave obeys
kill
oh my
juices
oh face
[Music]
this is what makes bioshock so hard to
speak about as so much of this game
revolves around this key moment and
summarizing the journey here in just a
few short sentences is a disservice to
the effort that went into creating this
plot twist right before this we actually
get to see a room that andrew ryan was
working in trying to piece together what
was going on he was confused why there
was some random person who just happened
to survive a plane crash right next to
the entrance to rapture and who is
capable of defeating all that he throws
in him by the time we arrive ryan
manages to uncover the truth we're a
sleeper agent for atlas we from birth
were created to be this way that child
of jasmine's that tenenbaum took from
her was us she paid jasmine for the baby
and conditioned the child to respond to
the phrase would you kindly meaning not
only was atlus lying to us we the player
never had any freedom in our choices and
to top it all off were ryan's son in
some ways it's almost poetic someone who
preaches about men choosing and slaves
obeying has a son who is the complete
opposite of him ryan a man and his son a
slave as if this plot twist wasn't
already bad enough the game isn't done
yet as when we take ryan's genetic key
and put it into the override we stop
rapture from self-destructing but now
give control of rapture to atlas who is
actually frank fontaine this wouldn't
have been as good if it was anyone but
fontaine the one who ran the smuggling
ring in neptune's bounty and the one who
worked with tenenbaum to condition us
was the guy who saved us the whole time
that room from earlier also shows us
some of the experiments jack underwent
before being sent out of rapture such as
when dr sung forced us to snap a dog's
neck because he said the phrase bioshock
without a doubt has one of the best if
not the best plot twist in gaming
history from the moment we have started
the game we had no free will the present
we were given sparked the plane crash so
even before we could play the game we
were being controlled video games as a
whole give the player a choice it could
be small choices like how to kill the
enemy in front of you or it could be a
large choice like the ending of a game
but bioshock took this idea and twisted
it completely by tricking the player
into thinking they had the freedom of
choice when in fact the only choice they
were given was when to turn the game off
this revelation also ties into four
things i've noticed over the years and
i've always wondered if they were
intentional or not firstly jack has a
tattoo of chains on his wrist possibly
signifying that he's a slave to atlas
next is when atlas's family who we
eventually discovered didn't actually
exist blows up in the bathysphere andrew
ryan says maybe you could warn him if
only you could do something except just
stand there and watch him die at this
time in the game ryan doesn't know who
we are so this wasn't intended to be a
double meaning but i believe the devs
made him say this on purpose as this
line can be interpreted as us once again
being a slave to atlas with no way to do
anything about it thirdly when we meet
the little sister at the medical
pavilion atlas never says the words
would you kindly it's possible that not
even tenenbaum knew of atlas's true
identity and if he had said that phrase
over the radio she would have caught on
immediately this is something fontaine
tries to do throughout the story and
that's to play the long game by
convincing us that his family died in
the bathysphere we made our bond with
him even stronger as we now have a
common goal but that's exactly what
fontaine wanted the last thing i noticed
was some symbolism in the first location
minutes into the game as there's a
statue holding up a ball with the words
welcome to rapture on it this is easily
a reference to atlas the greek giant who
was forced to hold up the world for all
eternity this could be seen as a
foreshadowing of atlus trying to hold up
the world of rapture by defeating ryan
and being the leader of the city but
it's also a reference to atlas's demise
as in greek mythology this was atlas's
punishment so this could be
foreshadowing atlas's punishment in game
as he just made us an enemy all of these
might be completely wrong but the fact
that they line up so well with the
game's themes and story make it
impossible to see it as a coincidence
from its plot twist to its symbolism
it's one of the best writing i've ever
seen however we're still not done with
the game yet fontaine has betrayed us
and without any real objective anymore
it's only fair that we enact the same
revenge again but on the man who
actually deserves it during the reveal
of fontaine he says goodbye and launches
an army of security bots to chase us
during our escape a little sister
appears and guides us to safety before
falling down the event shaft we awake
and then discover that we are in a
secret room in rapture where the little
sisters relax and play together it's a
really cute moment as we can see all the
little sisters interacting with one
another tenenbaum then informs us that
she was able to reduce some of the
mental conditioning that fontaine put on
us but we aren't completely cured to
achieve this we need to head to dr
sung's laboratory and find his cure for
it fontaine now the head of rapture
notices that we're awake and attempts to
shut us down but only ends up being able
to lower our health a bit by making our
heart stop momentarily it's a lot better
than being completely manipulated but he
can still control us in some way so we
definitely need that cure the location
where this cure is found is a place
called olympus heights where all the
super rich stayed in luxury apartments
many characters we've already talked
about today like tennenbaum dr sung and
even sandra cohen lived in these
apartments i've always found it
interesting how these apartments are
right next to apollo square which is
known for housing the poor and homeless
you can even tell from the railroad
station next to each area as the area
near olympus heights is quite pristine
given the circumstances and the one in
apollo square is extremely run down both
the audio logs and the environment will
tell us that there was clearly a
revolution starting here and at the head
of this was atlas in order to avoid
suspicion and hide under the radar
fontaine faked his own death and changed
his name and face to atlas we learned in
arcadia that atlas was at one point a
politician but he claimed those days
were over it seemed that fontaine was
using the poor as his army and there is
numerous audio logs to back this theory
up andrew ryan wanted to create the
perfect society but it fell victim to
social status and given his own policies
within rapture there wasn't much
opportunity to crawl back to the middle
class those who were rich succeeded and
those who were poor suffer just like
every other society in existence
fontaine sees this opportunity to gather
an army of like-minded individuals and
use them to do his bidding going back to
neptune's bounty we have a couple audio
logs from peaches that talk about how he
disliked ryan and preferred fontaine's
way of running things at least initially
until he realized that fontaine might
actually be worse than ryan this really
shows that even rapture was doomed to
fail as a society the only way it was
possible to save this city was for ryan
to help the poor and make sure everyone
was happy but given his own beliefs and
the beliefs of rapture that was never
gonna happen the downfall of rapture
didn't happen overnight it was a long
string of events that progressively got
worse and worse the atom addiction the
mistreatment of the poor the
manipulation of fontaine the actual
culture surrounding rapture all of it
contributed to its demise getting back
to the story we end up finding the cure
for our mental conditioning and allowed
jack complete freedom for the first time
in his life one thing that's important
to note is his freedom because it's not
like he was completely controlled he
still did things in his life before
coming to rapture but he was never
completely free as fontaine could easily
change that by saying one simple phrase
while gathering the cure we also found a
dead body on the table and discovered
that it's dr shu chong's quite ironic
that dr su chong died to his own
creation he was of course the original
creator of the big daddies and was the
one who created that defense mechanism
in them that attacks anyone who hurts
the little sisters good to see that he's
dead given how much pain he caused
people after finding the cure we can now
kill fontaine except before we get a
chance to heal locks the door of the
educational facility which is only
unlocked via a big daddy which means we
need to become a big daddy despite how
bothersome this area can be in regards
to its confusing layout and plethora of
enemies from a lore perspective it's
quite intriguing as this is the facility
where the big daddies and little sisters
were made one thing that's been missing
from this game so far is the who the big
daddies are and how they were made and
thankfully this area answers that
question it seems that the big daddies
are people who had their skin and organs
grafted to the suits which may explain
why they can't take them off in jack's
case he didn't need to graft his skin
and organs to the suit as he just needed
to trick the system into thinking he was
a big daddy which is why he isn't
injured during the process however he
does need a voice module so he can sound
like one and just by looking at the
device it definitely doesn't look safe
after becoming a big daddy we help out a
little sister who gives us a syringe and
unlocks the final locked door to
fontaine where we can now finally start
the boss fight and both this and the
endings of bioshock are honestly quite
bad fontaine is a giant creature now
flowing with adam and while i'm willing
to just barely believe something like
this is possible the fight overall is
just bad all you do during the fight is
shoot him until his health is gone and
then when he returns to his machine to
gather more atom you stab him with the
syringe and you do this four times until
he dies you would think after the second
time he would stop recharging his atom
this way but apparently not the boss
fight does ramp up in difficulty as the
security bots and splicers come to his
aid but it's sort of hard to ignore the
giant naked man trying to kill you
especially when he functions just like a
big daddy and stuns you when you're hit
after defeating him he'll smack you one
more time and all the little sisters
will come out and aid you by stabbing
him which admittedly is pretty cool
afterwards the game goes into one of
three endings and the conditions of the
ending depend on whether or not you
harvested or saved the little sisters
one ending is when you save all of them
the other is when you harvest all of
them and a third is if you do a mix of
both you don't need to rescue every
single little sister but out of the ones
you interacted with within the game you
do have to save them i do like the happy
ending where all the little sisters grow
up and live normal lives before all
meeting again to be with you on your
deathbed but the other is just bizarre
as jack takes control of rapture for
himself and uses the splicers as an army
to overtake the surface and launch a
nuke like the ending started okay but
ramped up in intensity immediately why
does jack need a nuke why bother killing
those on the surface what was even the
point of this ending this just like the
morality of harvesting and rescuing the
little sisters was something the
developers wish they'd improved on for
the final release regardless we have
made it to the end of the game and thus
finish the story of bioshock this game
is without a doubt one of the best of
all time it truly has one of the best
stories in the gaming industry and is
one i wish i could experience again for
the first time bioshock has an
incredible level of detail put into its
story from its world building to its
story of specific characters this couple
with its incredible plot twist makes
this a very hard game to beat when it
comes to comparing its stories it's one
game i will always recommend without
hesitation and was the perfect start to
a brand new series bioshock 2 is
perfection it took what was wrong with
bioshock 1 and changed it for the better
but it also kept its strongest narrative
devices in the game making it feel like
how a bioshock game should this
ultimately created a perfect version of
bioshock that i feel doesn't get enough
credit so today i want to discuss why i
think that without further ado
let's get started as always we need to
start at the beginning a cutscene
showcases that we are in 1958. if you
recall from the lore that is only a year
before the new year's attacks in 1959.
so currently things should be quite
civil and for the most part they are we
see a first person view of a big daddy
talking with a little sister to which he
follows her around the halls she ends up
running on a head before getting caught
by some thugs just like any big daddy
would he decimates the thugs with ease
before being hypnotized afterwards
though a woman named sophia lam enters
the room
there we are
he's perfectly safe now
this is not your daughter
do you understand
her name is eleanor and she is mine
now
neil please
remove your helmet
now
take the pistol
place it against your head
[Music]
fire
honestly it's a great intro and we can
learn a lot from it firstly while
walking with a little sister we get a
sneak peek at the big daddy guiding her
and it's a model we haven't seen yet in
the series on top of that the little
girl has a name eleanor throughout the
series we aren't told little sister's
name so this was done intentionally to
paint her as an important character even
further we actually see the big daddy
remove his helmet this is also a first
for the series as we know big daddies
were regular people who had
modifications done to their body so they
could fit the role of the big daddy such
as voice modification mental
conditioning and the grafting of the
skin to the suit itself but this doesn't
seem to be the case the only character
who's capable of doing this is jack and
bioshock1 but as we know he only needed
to seem like a big daddy so he could
bypass the facility's lockdown if you
want to see more of this i did talk
about bioshock 1 in a previous video
which will be linked at the end of this
one or in the eye in the top right right
now so questions are already flooding
the player's mind and it's enough to
either get them hooked immediately or at
least get their attention mind you this
is only three minutes into the game so
we're starting off quite strong bioshock
1 had the element of surprise as the
player wasn't accustomed to rapture just
yet that's why sudden reveal landed so
well but doing that again wouldn't have
the same effect so bioshock 2 needed to
ramp up the intensity and not only does
the intro start off incredibly strong it
keeps going as the character we play
throughout the game is a big daddy words
can't describe how excited i was when
seeing this there is no doubt in my mind
that at least once the rada playthrough
of bioshock won you must have thought
how cool it would have been to play as
one while our prayers have been answered
as playing as the big daddy is arguably
the greatest feeling in the series from
the actual moment-to-moment gameplay to
the interactions with the little sisters
the big daddy is such a great character
for the player to control as if all this
wasn't great already the game introduces
the newest character to the roster the
big sister these two represent a sort of
dichotomy battling over a common goal
quite early in the game we take our
first plasmid and come across a little
sister since we're a big daddy our duty
is to obviously protect her except the
big sister swipes her away from us the
problem is that the big sisters were
designed to also protect the little
sisters so firstly where did she even
come from but secondly why are they
actively working against us despite
having a common goal bioshock as a
series has never shielded away from
secrecy mystery and confusion especially
in its early moments already within just
a few minutes we're given multiple
breadcrumb trails and while not forced
to follow said trail why wouldn't you
after going through this intro who is
the big sister who are we why aren't we
a normal big daddy who's eleanor and who
is sophia lamb these questions are the
driving force behind why the player
continues deeper into the game bioshock
2 had a tough job of continuing the
series after the very satisfying
conclusion of the previous game it also
had to get the player interested despite
giving all of its secrets away in that
previous game and somehow bioshock 2
nailed it perfectly some games have been
able to pull this off before but only
few have been truly able to do this
within a couple minutes of game time and
the fact that bioshock 2 can replicate
the same mysterious feeling of bioshock
1 with the added penalty of having its
vast world building already known by the
player deserves some praise so now that
i'm done rambling about the game's
mystery i think it's time to finally
explain that mystery i've always been a
sucker for lore in games if it wasn't
evident by the videos on this channel
and bioshock 2's newly added concepts in
world building are moderately brilliant
just like bioshock 1 the majority of the
story will come from audio diaries
random devices we can find throughout
the world however bioshock 1 ran into an
issue with these devices many of the
audio diaries focused on key characters
whether that was the main boss of an
area like dr steinmann or was a part of
rapture's high society like tenenbaum
and andrew ryan it felt like rapture
only revolved around a few people and
that never sat right with me bioshock 2
changes this completely as while some
notable characters will have numerous
appearances throughout the game like
sophia lamb andrew ryan and tenenbaum
there's also a large number of audio
logs made by just random people who had
way more world building than bioshock 1
ever did we'll circle back to him in a
moment but a good example is mark
meltzer his audio diaries detail his
investigation into rapture and his
daughter sydney as he believes his
daughter was kidnapped and brought here
for an unknown reason originally it
seems like just a one-off diary but not
only does just this one diary explain
that people from the surface have found
an invaded rapture but he has more
diaries that show up throughout the game
and it makes you want to see the outcome
of his investigation like i said even if
it was just a one-off diary the fact
that people like mark can even find
rapture is incredible to begin with
rapture was built to be away from
society both far and deep enough that
only those who were invited would know
yet somehow random people are able to
find it and that's a big issue just this
one diary finally provided an
astronomical amount of world building
and makes rapture feel like a living
breathing city besides the miscellaneous
audio diaries a good portion of them
still deal with a lot of information
that is necessary to understanding
what's going on so the intro was in 1958
but the game actually takes place 10
years later in 1968. we are subject
delta and alpha series big daddy not
only are we a part of the first line of
big daddies but we're the first ever big
daddy to be bonded with a little sister
on top of this being an alpha series is
quite different than being a regular big
daddy firstly alpha series big daddies
don't have the skin grafted to their
suit which explains why delta could take
off his helmet in the intro furthermore
the alpha series is only intended to
bond with one little sister during their
creation the person inside the suit was
fitted with an unbreakable psychological
bond with one little sister should this
bond be broken by the death of the
little sister or the separation of the
two for an extended period of time the
alpha series will either collapse and
enter a coma-like state or be driven mad
with rage one of the audio diaries even
talks about someone seeing one of the
alpha series big daddies crying at a
gatherer's garden because they couldn't
find their little sister this idea
clearly had many drawbacks as the big
daddies would be completely useless
should the little sister die this is why
they changed the typical big daddies we
see more frequently in bioshock 1. ones
who still protect the little sisters but
don't have a specific bond with a
particular one making them a bit more
useful this unbreakable bond we just
discussed is why delta is so adamant on
finding eleanor when he awakes but
clearly he wasn't just a suit of armor
all his life as we know all big daddies
were humans at some point in delta's
case he was just a deep-sea diver on the
surface who accidentally came across
rapture he actually had an article
written in the paper about him ryan
didn't believe this story and thought
that he was a spy so he had him
incarcerated his old life would then
come to an end when he was selected to
be a part of the big daddy program
leaving his old name and identity behind
being only known as delta after the
cutscene in the intro delta wakes up
after the events of bioshock 1. so
andrew ryan and fontaine are already
dead the first words we hear upon waking
up are from a familiar voice tenenbaum
it seems that even though rapture is
practically a barren wasteland she
decided to stay behind or at least
that's what it seems like tenenbaum
actually came back to rapture thanks to
sophia lamb rapture is an extremely
captivating place not just in ideals but
in location substitute out that
objectivism that andrew ryan prodded
into the city and swapped that with
literally anything and you can get a
ultimate utopia of that ideal rapture is
a secluded place away from the rest of
the world so literally anything involved
with rapture could have blossomed from
such a location like let's say a cult
rapture in bioshock 2 is now under new
management with sofia lamb being the
leader who has rallied the people behind
the banner of the family you may
actually recognize sophia as throughout
the first game there was a poster
showing rapture's best and brightest and
in the back resides sophia before and
during her time in rapture she was a
clinical psychiatrist anger ryan had
invited her to rapture so that she could
provide counseling to the isolated
members of rapture overall it sounded
like a great deal for both parties
involved but sophia quickly realized
that the cause of this problem was the
person who hired her to solve it andrew
ryan see rapture under ryan was built
around objectivism something i had
completely neglected to bring up in the
previous video so thank you all the
comments for mentioning that to me
objectivism is defined as quote the
concept of man as a heroic being with
his own happiness as the moral purpose
of his life with productive achievement
as his noblest activity and reason as
his only absolute but sophia had a more
altruistic look on life as she had hoped
to enlighten the citizens of rapture
through a common good she would do this
by providing free therapy to the poor
and intentionally losing at poker so she
could spread her wealth to the less
fortunate anger ryan actively wanted the
people to push themselves and seek their
true greatness on their own without
anyone hindering their progress but
sophia was actively going against that
by helping others this caused the two to
clash heads on multiple occasions even
having live debates on specific topics
and it was also during this time that
sophia was actively helping the poor and
fontaine was also trying to undermine
ryan using fontaine futuristics so when
it was discovered that both fontaine and
ryan were dead it made sense that she
became the newest owner her altruistic
outlook on life also helped her gain
that favor as the people of rapture saw
her as a kind woman willing to help
those who were less fortunate but she
knew this wouldn't last she would either
be overtaken by some other force of
nature or she would die from natural
causes so to continue her goal she ended
up teaching her daughter in hopes of
becoming her perfect vessel eleanor is
her daughter yes the little sister that
delta had bonded with is none other than
the new queen of rapture's daughter it's
such a great twist and it raises the
stakes of our missions tenfold so far
this is the story of rapture in bioshock
2 but i've neglected to bring up
tenenbaum as i said tenenbaum did leave
rapture and so did all the little
sisters but she discovered that more
girls were disappearing so she came back
to rapture to find out someone was
making little sisters again so she came
down here to put an end to it as you
remember tenenbaum was the creator of
the little sisters but after she
realized the pain in suffering this
cause she regretted her actions and
dedicated her time to stopping what she
created but now she has to do it all
over again this is the full complete
backstory that sets the foundation of
bioshock 2. it's quite a lot and can get
complex at times but this is exactly
what i was looking for i wanted bioshock
2 to take the already established story
of bioshock 1 and make that the
foundation for the sequel and this
integration exceeded my expectations so
far we've been getting a little ahead of
ourselves so let's dial it back a bit
and continue where we left off in game
currently we're still in the early
minutes of the game and already sophie's
cult-like following is starting to show
itself as there are paintings tributes
and murals dedicated to her there's no
shortage of these in bioshock 2 truly
showing how far her influence goes in
rapture and alternatively how alone and
outnumbered we are again accompanying
these tributes is a book called unity
and metamorphosis it's all about the
creation of a perfect paradise through
unity and the abandonment of the self
this also coincides with all the imagery
and messages of butterflies and being
reborn just as a caterpillar is reborn
into a butterfly a butterfly is vastly
different compared to a caterpillar
which is why it's considered two
different insects despite being the same
thing sophia planned on using eleanor as
a vessel for her ideologies by basically
shutting her away from the world while
she teaches her she would then show the
family eleanor how she is the first
utopian who was able to abandon herself
and become truly free the problem is
that sophia has to convince the rest of
rapture to do the same and while many
are on her side aligning herself with
her is a lot different than changing
your way of thinking permanently
thankfully depending on how you look at
it sophia did find a rather interesting
discovery sophia discovered the story of
jack and realized that this mental
conditioning could be used to make
people uphold the common good this
proves that sofia is just as flawed as
everyone else she is literally following
in the footsteps of fontaine and is
considering using a type of conditioning
that reprograms the brain and forces
people not to think for themselves just
like we talked about before this is
another example of bioshock 2 taking key
parts from the previous game and
reworking it in the sequel now the
phrase would you kindly isn't seen as a
way to manipulate someone to do your
bidding but it's seen as a necessary
step to be able to live freely in a
utopia it's these slight twists on
already familiar material that makes the
story very engaging again continuing
through the level we finally get to face
off against the big sister and it's here
and a few other places later in the game
via audio diaries where we discover
where these big sisters came from these
big sisters were originally little
sisters the atom in their body became
too problematic as they grew older and
thus the older sisters were moved into
different roles we also find out that it
was the big sisters who were abducting
the new little sisters from the surface
which explains the vast population of
little sisters still in rapture again
there isn't any other lore besides this
but it does answer a fairly good
question in regards to what happens when
the sisters get older irrational games
could have easily just said that because
rapture is so large we didn't rescue all
the little sisters thus why they're
still populating the city but this
approach to its world building was a
much better choice so nice job as we
approach the end of the first area we
encounter sophia for the first time very
similarly to how we encounter ryan
except instead of atlas trying to help
us it's tenenbaum she then explains that
she can help us get to eleanor or she
can see through the camera in our
helmets except i'm not really even sure
why they brought this up as it's never
used again we meet tenenbaum one time in
person and then afterwards we never hear
another word from her we get more info
on her whereabouts and time and rapture
from audio diaries again which is a
shame as these audio diaries tell us a
lot of important information that i
would have loved for her to elaborate on
now to be fair these audio logs are in
the dlc which we'll talk about later but
still i wish that she would have had
much more of an appearance this game
instead we're going to be guided by
augustus sinclair and i 100
blame bioshock 1 for this because i did
not trust him the entire game he feels
the exact same role as atlas a guy we
don't know who just wants to help us for
seemingly no reason but the whole time
he was talking i was just waiting for
him to backstab us but it never came
true upon entering the second area we
hear eleanor's voice and discover that
she can talk to us telepathically and is
actively trying to aid us by bringing us
gifts in plasmids it's not clear how she
can do this but it's explained later one
thing you'll notice from playing this
game is the lack of levels in bioshock
2. the game only has 9 areas compared to
its predecessor's 14 and while that's
not a large difference it's still a
lesser amount but what bioshock 2 lacks
in quantity it makes up for in quality
each of these levels is 3 4 or 5 levels
high filled with rubble objects enemies
and other gear for the player to look at
these places feel lived in and real
which is always a nice feeling you'll be
spending much more time in these levels
individually than compared to bioshock
1. both games did take me around the
same time to complete yet one game had
less levels than the other meaning i was
spending more time in those levels
engaging with the environment and
dealing with puzzles and all the enemies
it threw at me bioshock 1 also did feel
quite linear at times places like the
proving grounds and the medical pavilion
were great but some of the levels felt
way too linear for the genre all the
levels in bioshock 2 are completely
non-linear you'll be constantly
backtracking to the same places and not
only does this add to the gameplay loop
of finding new enemies in the same
locations but it also plays into the
story and how it's continually trying to
reinforce how large these areas within
rapture are and how expansive this city
really is my only complaint is the odd
amount of similarity between some of the
levels as sometimes it's hard to
determine what level you're really on
besides a few specific areas bioshock 1
really nailed the diversity of the level
to level gameplay to where no level
really looked the same i will admit
though that this is quite the subjective
stance however something that is
objectively better than before is the
way the game handles the little sisters
in our last video talking about bioshock
1 i mentioned that while on paper the
choice of saving and harvesting the
little sisters was cool in practice it
was extremely one-sided as it favored
rescuing the little sisters thus ruining
the choice of morality bioshock 2
reduces the number of little sisters
from 21 down to 12. on top of this
rescuing the little sister requires you
to defeat the big daddy protecting her
then escort her to two bodies in the
level to extract adam from once that's
done only then can you rescue them this
is made way more difficult thanks to
bioshock 2's amp difficulty the game
isn't impossible but you start out with
a max of 5 eve and health slots rather
than your 9 in bioshock 1. your weapons
also don't feel nearly as powerful
sometimes and enemies do hit a lot
harder plus there's also more big
daddies as you'll be constantly fighting
more alpha series versions as we get
closer to the game's epilogue
furthermore every four little sisters
that you rescue or harvest will spawn a
big sister who while does drop 40 atom
is without a doubt the hardest enemy in
the game after everything is all said
and done upon looking at the numbers the
actual difference isn't that far off
it's actually less than the previous
game with a difference of 90 atom
according to the wiki but the tasks
required to get that atom makes
harvesting seem like the much better
option as if all this wasn't bad enough
already something we discover from the
audio logs later in the game is that the
little sisters despite being immortal do
experience some degree of pain as one
fell over a railing and broke her leg
and when they tried to snap it back into
place it was clear from her facial
reactions that she was experiencing pain
makes you think about the next time you
unload a few rockets near her when you
try to take down the big daddy relating
back to the story this is what
irrational games had intended for the
first game giving the player an easy but
morally wrong option and a hard but
morally right option to see if it's
enough to break the player's values is
the struggle to hold off waves of
splicers enough to make you snap and
just take the atom for yourself by force
this idea also makes the ending much
more important but we'll get to that
later the fourth area of the game is
popper's drop and is our first instance
of a boss-like character similar to dr
styman from bioshock 1. in this area we
have grace holloway who runs this
section of rapture and is eagerly
waiting to kill us according to the
audio logs we find about her grace was a
singer here in rapture who caught the
eye of a james who was enjoying her
singing he seemed to enjoy when people
were real when it came to rapture and
willing to talk about its flaws this
caused him to be noticed by ryan and
then taken away never to be heard of
again she would then hear of sophia lamb
and how she was giving away free
counseling and then was swindled into
her family she joined her group of
people and because of how important she
was to sophia when ryan eventually came
for sophia and locked her up in prison
she gave eleanor to grace so that she
may look after her however this didn't
last long as eleanor was kidnapped and
sold to the little sisters orphanage
which explains how she became a little
sister in the first place once she
became a little sister she would then
bond to us and we would then become her
current guardian this explains why grace
is extremely mad at our arrival in
pauper's drop claiming that we stole
eleanor from her the reason this is
relevant is because all of this
information is key to understanding her
character and thus determining her fate
at the end of the level bioshock 2
introduces the option of killing or
sparing three key people and our first
is grace holloway when you enter grace's
quarters you're given the choice of
killing or sparing her it's quite easy
to just kill her and leave since she
started fighting you but given her
backstory i ultimately decided to spare
her she was just a poor and lost woman
down in rapture and when sophia was able
to bring her out of her own hell of
course she was going to help her as much
as she could plus we can't blame her for
not understanding the bond between
eleanor and delta neither wanted to
become little sisters or big daddies
even as an alpha series model yes your
skin isn't grafted to the suit but
you're still heavily spliced with adam
and of course as we know most if not all
the big daddies were unwilling
participants we never chose this life
but grace doesn't know that so we can't
blame her for trying to kill us if you
spare her she goes on to say that she
was wrong about you she still believes
that sophia isn't a liar but she knows
that she is at least wrong about delta
our second character is stanley pool at
diana's park still continuing to be
altruistic sofia also had a hand in the
creation of the park which served as a
both an art and cultural exhibit hosted
by sophia herself she created this as
both a way for her to undermine ryan's
ideals and also a way to promote her own
ryan's main philosophy with rapture was
a city without morals or sensors so
naturally all art should be accepted in
rapture until sophia started using this
against him and started showcasing art
opposite of ryan's ideology this of
course led to her art being censored by
the general public showing that rapture
was a place that accepted these
qualities but as long as ryan agreed to
it to make matters worse for ryan his
own version of this was arcadia from
bioshock 1 except ryan charged his
visitors whereas sofia made this exhibit
free to the public due to this attack on
his character ryan had enough of lamb
and sent a spy to infiltrate her network
this spy was stanley pool stanley was
quite successful in feeding information
to ryan but so much so that it led to
sofia being imprisoned he would then
during this time used the money sophia
had to throw parties at the park in an
attempt to eradicate her funds however
during this time eleanor caught wind of
these parties and confronted stanley
about it fearing he would be caught he
was the one who kidnapped eleanor and
gave her up to the little sisters
orphanage in the present day stanley has
flooded the exhibit fearing that sophia
and the other members in the family
would rat him out as ryan's spy he stays
held up in there for years until delta
arrives at the park while we're only
here to just pass by and get to fontaine
futuristic stanley refuses to let us
pass until we deal with all the little
sisters despite all the witnesses being
dead stanley fears that when the little
sisters drain the victims adam they'll
discover the truth and relay the info
back to sophia so he wants us to get rid
of them but by helping the little
sisters we can also uncover the full
story for ourselves what is shown is the
info we just previously went over with
him kidnapping eleanor and throwing
massive parties at sofia's expense when
we approach stanley sophia hops on the
microphone and says that he is the
reason we're a big daddy and that she
knew for years that he was a spy we are
now once again given the option of
killing or sparing him this decision was
probably the hardest one for me to do
stanley is responsible for our new life
but he wasn't the only one at fault he
wrote the article about delta being the
mysterious deep-sea diver the article
didn't seem like it was malicious ryan
was the only one who saw delta as a
threat so the blame now goes to ryan but
ryan just simply imprisoned us it was
sinclair who would then offer us a job
at fontaine futuristics as a performer
who tested plasmids in front of a live
audience these performances made him a
candidate for the big daddy program so
sinclair is now to blame but dr su chong
and gilbert alexander created the big
daddy program so they're to blame as
well do you see where this is going no
one person is truly responsible for
delta's new life it was just coincidence
after coincidence and he was just at the
wrong places at the wrong time every
time you could however claim that
because he heard eleanor and turned her
into a little sister he should be
punished but this argument is quite
shallow all of these decisions that
happened between us and eleanor led to
us being bonded together but if
something changed then we could have
been bonded with someone else see we
arrived later or even earlier to rapture
then eleanor would have likely never
bonded with us so there is no argument
in saying that we should harm stanley
for how we treated eleanor because not
only did we not know her even prior to
our own transformation you could
technically even argue that we should be
grateful to him for bringing us together
although i don't really subscribe to
that idea either despite this there is a
lot of reasons to not spare him and that
is because of his other actions like
killing the witnesses and clearly
showing that he'll do whatever it takes
including murder to get his way it's due
to this confliction that i ultimately
decided to spare stanley he wasn't the
sole reason we're a big daddy and the
idea that we should harm him for what he
did to eleanor makes no sense either our
third and final character is gilbert
alexander his introduction starts off
quite different than what we're used to
as we hear an audio recording tell us to
kill him and then we see him piloting a
security bot all while yelling at a
group of splicers this is quite the
twist as we have a man who is telling us
to kill him because he's going to become
clinically insane but then also having
that new insane self tell us not to kill
him it's also during this level where we
can meet mark meltzer the guy who
investigated rapture so he could find
his daughter or at least what was left
of him anyway it seems that despite all
he went through he was caught by sophia
and turned into a big daddy on the plus
side however according to the audio log
that was found in his body the little
sister he bonded with was his daughter
cindy so at least they got to be
together forever well at least until we
killed him you don't discover that this
is mark until after his death which
makes you feel quite sad as you just
tore his daughter from him so i made it
up to mark by restoring his daughter to
her former self in hopes that she can
have a brighter future it's incredible
how bioshock makes you care about mark
and cindy despite them rarely ever
showing up you know what happens to the
little girls in rapture so that makes
the situation even worse as we now
finally got to see the other side of the
coin we're not able to see how the
parents react to their daughter being
taken bioshock 1 did this as well with
another individual but i felt it was
much better handled here going back to
gilbert since we have to decide his fate
the question is then what's his story
well gilbert alexander was a researcher
at rapture who specialized in robotic
and mechanical engineering he was also
the creator of the alpha series big
daddies and was responsible for the
unbreakable bond that they have built
into them as we know it worked too well
making them not as efficient and
protecting all the little sisters as it
only made them care about one this idea
was inevitably thrown out but due to his
knowledge of the bonding process and the
manufacturing of the suits he assisted
dr sung in creating the new line of big
daddies after some time though he began
to feel guilty about his actions sofia
used the skill to manipulate him into
being her own test subject
dr alexander has agreed to accept both
measures of the new utopian project he
will become a kind of genetic chimera
host to all the minds of rapture
accessing their talents and memories via
the adam we have gathered
and deriving in part from project wyk
i have developed a new set of behavioral
constraints
dr alexander will live to promote the
common good she wanted to use gilbert as
a test subject to see if she could
create the first utopian being capable
of losing self-interest and being
extremely loving and loyal to the human
race this however did not go as planned
i was to be sophia lamb's greatest
achievement a living composite of all
raptures genius in the body of a single
man
unfettered by self-interest
now i am nothing more to her than a
failed experiment
my scores on tests of intelligence and
moral reasoning are still noteworthy but
declining sharply
she has abandoned me and i do not have
long before psychosis takes me this is
what led to gilbert making the audio
logs we hear about how to kill him once
he becomes insane after entering the
core of fontaine futuristics we can see
him in his final form which is this
giant amalgamation inside of a water
tank it looks awful we then for the
final time have to decide another
person's fate this is the only person in
the game i killed and i also killed
without hesitation i deemed it as a
mercy killing more than anything this
does become quite the tough argument
when you consider that it's possible
that after being clinically insane he
enjoyed his new life and thus killing
him would have been a bad thing it's
ultimately his words against his own and
personally i'd rather believe the
version that was able to think more
rationally rather than the one that was
mutated beyond human recognition that's
why i felt that it was a good idea to
kill him so i could rid him of his
suffering and allow him to finally die
as a whole these choices were really
well done and judging from some of the
community discussions i've seen and many
have chosen the alternate solutions that
i didn't choose i read many posts saying
that they killed grace holloway for
trying to fight them that they killed
stanley for turning us into a big daddy
and some even spared gilbert because
they believed that his past self wants
to die but his present self doesn't want
to and thus they spared him this shows
that these choices were well written
enough that it wasn't clear what the
best choice was in the moment makes you
think about your decision and what led
to things being like how they are now
and that's once again extremely
impressive after dealing with gilbert we
make it to persephone which is rapture's
prison system and is also where we find
eleanor as we approach her sophia stops
us and locks us out she goes on to
explain that eleanor wanted a father and
tried to make one again an audio log
clears this up but basically eleanor has
the power to control the little sisters
and through this power she managed to
find a gene sample of delta she planned
on using this sample to revive delta
through a vita chamber and sure enough
it worked this explains how we survived
the gunshot wound we didn't actually
survive eleanor just revived us she also
used the little sisters to contact
tenenbaum so that she could help us get
back up on our feet now things are
starting to make a bit more sense but
just as we're about to be let inside
sophia smothers eleanor with a pillow
temporarily stopping us due to our
unbreakable bond however it was only for
a specific amount of time as sophia
obviously wants to keep eleanor alive as
that's literally her daughter so it
wasn't enough time to kill her but it
was enough to break our bond with her
when we awake we're strapped down and
can't move but eleanor lets us take
control of one of the little sisters so
that we can unlock our own restraints as
simple as this sequence was it was
probably one of my favorites in the
entire game as we got to see the world
through the eyes of the little sister
for the very first time and it truly
shows how deep the mental conditioning
went they don't even see the same world
that we do it's completely different
this was more than likely made so that
the girls didn't have to see the horrors
of the real world and thus can continue
to do their jobs without being scared
this explains why everything is so clean
and new in their world and why the big
sister suit isn't a diving suit but a
dress and why there's petals instead of
blood when we do extract the blood from
the splicers though it does come back to
the real world and i don't think this
happens to the girls i think it's just
more of a game design decision to remind
us that we're still in rapture meaning
the girls after becoming little sisters
never see the real world again until we
save them this was such a great section
and really shows how badly their minds
were altered after using the little
sister to gather the big sister suit we
give it to eleanor who uses it to break
out of her containment and then release
us as well we also get a plasmid that
can summon her from any location which
is really cool as it shows sophia that
despite the bond being physically broken
their love for one another knows no
bounds by talking with eleanor we
discover that she has a plan which is to
take sinclair's lifeboat up to the
surface except sophia is trying to stop
us while trying to throt her plans at
stopping us we run into sinclair again
except time this is not on good terms it
seems that he was captured and made into
a big daddy we can hear his voice over
the radio getting more and more
desperate as he tries to find a way out
of the suit he then tells us to unlock
the door and finish him off even though
he desperately wanted to live and be on
the surface again dying is better than
being a controlled test subject after
getting the device from sinclair and
also helping eleanor rescue the little
sisters that are in the nearby wing we
use the little sisters by having them
boil the water underneath the lifeboat
so it can rise i'll be honest i don't
remember if this was ever explained in
the entire series ever but the only
thing i can assume is that they're
expelling the atom in their systems
which heats the water somehow as we
finish heating the lifeboat the
explosives that sofia planted explode
and cause us to get knocked back
thankfully we're just barely able to
latch onto the lifeboat as it floats up
and it's here where we discover the
ending of the game but it's done a bit
differently this time there are six
possible endings but it's all because of
the combination of two choices the
harvesting and rescuing from bioshock 1
returns again but the sparing and
killing of the previous characters is
also a factor there's actually a neat
little flowchart someone made to help
visualize them sparing lives actually
has different weight depending on your
choices with the little sisters if you
spared all the girls then saving one
character will give you the best ending
but if you harvest a couple of little
sisters then you must spare all of them
to get that same ending this goes even
further with the bad ending is when you
harvest all the little sisters sparing
the three characters is still not enough
and then you're stuck in the bad ending
now this is only for determining whether
or not sofia lives the other decision is
eleanor and delta's fate if you rescue
all the little sisters then eleanor will
drain delta's adam and transfer it into
her so that his memories and
consciousness can live inside of her and
the two can be together forever if you
harvest all the little sisters eleanor
shows no remorse and drains all of his
atom for herself killing delta as she
says that we taught her not to let
things go to waste however these endings
are different from bioshock 1 and not
just in the actual cutscenes but it's
how it's determined remember eleanor can
control and look through the eyes of the
little sisters because of this she was
able to witness all the rescuing and
harvesting we did to them as well as the
decisions we made regarding the three
important people we discussed before and
it's these decisions that play into the
ending of the game whereas bioshock 1
had a similar structure which changed
the ending based on our decisions with
the sisters it's not outlandish to find
this a bit odd as some could have simply
just used the sisters for extra atom to
survive rapture and had no intentions of
taking the girls for themselves or using
them in the splashes to rule rapture but
with bioshock 2 your decisions don't
affect you but your own daughter just as
a parent can influence their child's
behavior we as the parent influenced
eleanor's outlook on life such as
whether or not people should be forgiven
for their past mistakes and a bit more
directly eleanor got to see how caring
and ruthless delta was like i said
earlier when we get the bad ending she
explains how we taught her not to let
things go to waste and that bad people
should be punished for their actions no
matter how small or insignificant they
were this adds another layer to the
endings overall as these aren't just
decisions that affect the ending of the
game but decisions that affect eleanor
which then affect the ending of the game
this was mind-blowing what i had looked
into the endings and how they were
determined and it's just outright
incredible while the ending of bioshock
2 marks the end of the game it's not
really the end of the game as bioshock 2
came with a couple dlcs one of which was
a side story called minerva's den as
opposed to the main game minerva's then
takes a bit longer to set up the story
instead of our main character being
subject delta we now play a subject
sigma another alpha series big daddy as
we approach a tunnel it gets blown up
and we're sent into the sea floor we
hear a man on the radio named charles
milton porter who instructs us to find
the thinker we then eventually get
introduced to reed wall both him and
porter were the founders of this device
called the thinker which is great except
we don't know what it is of course in
typical bioshock fashion an audio log
explains it instead the thinker is a
giant computer that uses atom to process
data at the speed of thought it's the
sole reason that rapture can even
operate it's quite a neat device but
both reid and porter discovered it could
do so much more this is what caused a
split between the two founders reed
wanted to use the thinker as a
prediction machine so it can bet on the
ball games and see the changes in the
stock market but porter wanted to create
artificial intelligence but more
specifically he just wanted to replicate
the mind of his dead wife pearl who died
during a german bombing during our
travels through minerva's den we can
also find some audio logs of tenenbaum
which explains why she disappeared
during the main story she was trying to
find a cure for adam adam and the
sickness that comes with repeated use is
the main reason rapture turned out this
way in the first place and if tenenbaum
can find a cure she can not only help
those who are still alive within rapture
but also be able to take this and the
plasmids to the surface with the safety
of knowing that whatever happened in
rapture won't happen again she sadly
hasn't gotten very far in her research
as there is still a ton of variables
that require calculation which is why
she wants the thinker as she believes it
could solve her problem instantly this
is why she works with porter as they
both want the thinker to survive so they
can use it for good on the surface this
is a much better introduction and now
provides the reason as to why we're
tasked with finding the device in the
first place is we can now change the
world with the thinker the only problem
is we don't know who we are however that
will be explained a bit later sadly
though after this there isn't much in
terms of a present day story the main
game suffers the same problem where it's
really just one objective that you need
to complete like finding eleanor which
takes the entire game however bioshock 2
splits up this objective by forcing you
to interact with new people and even
make some decisions except minerva's
then doesn't do that from the start to
the end the main objective is to stop
read and find the thinker there are no
other characters present in this dlc
besides reed porter tenenbaum and sigma
you don't make any choices and there is
only one ending so it's really just a
long string of tedious objectives that
are broken up by more combat i said the
same thing in bioshock 1 when talking
about the arcadia and market levels
taking into account the gameplay the
exploration and the story these levels
flow really well and are fun to have
combat encounters in but when just
looking at the story itself it suffers
there just really isn't anything going
on it's like the dlc has a heavy focus
of story in the beginning and the end of
the playthrough while the combat takes
up the middle thankfully the audio logs
do break up some of the pace and allow
for more story to creep in but all this
is story from the past i'm talking about
things that are happening in the here
and now like once again how we learn
about the three characters in the main
story then choose to spare or kill them
or when we finally meet eleanor but then
sophia stops us by breaking our bond
together these are things that are
happening in the present and are shaping
the story the dlc does not have any of
that the first level of the game is
about going from one area to the next
grabbing items so you can open up new
areas until you finally complete the
whole level this continues all the way
up to the final few minutes of the game
as all we're really trying to do is just
make it to the core of the central
computing wing so we can find the
thinker throughout the whole time in
this dlc most of our interactions with
these people is just porter giving us
instructions and reed projecting a very
cocky attitude because he believes that
the thinker can stop us since it can
predict any outcome except later we
discover that isn't entirely true it is
calculating what we'll do but according
to the equation once we reach the core
it just stops this worries him as the
outcome is undetermined something pretty
much impossible to happen to the thinker
this problem of his happens around the
time we enter his office and it's where
we discover that because of this beef
reid took it upon himself to frame
porter for a crime he didn't commit and
have him thrown in jail since he was in
jail the thinker would be his to control
and now he could use it for whatever he
wants but the thinker never chose reid
as much as he thinks this to be the case
in fact i don't think it really chose
anyone however it did assist porter
well thinker
ryan secret police are on their way
they cooked up some kind of evidence
against me treason they say
i've heard what happens to folks who get
disappeared come back as one of those
metal daddies
so
i'm leaving you with something to
cogitate on in my absence
inputting rapture departure protocol
figure a way to get yourself out of this
city thinker
you've got to live on no matter what
happens to me
so before being shipped off to prison
porter created a program so that the
thinker could escape reed's grasp this
makes sense as when we enter the last
few minutes of the game reed discovers
that the thinker wasn't working with him
but against him it's also around this
time where reed expresses his confusion
as to how porter walked out of
persephone unscathed and an idea came
into my head and for the very first time
in this series i finally predicted
something because we discover that
subject sigma is charles milton porter
going back to that rapture departure
protocol the thinker determined that the
best possible way for him to escape was
to enlist the help of porter himself to
get sigma to follow the thinker he used
the personality duplication program
which is what porter designed when he
tried to replicate his wife but the
thinker instead replicated porter's own
mind besides being a bit of an obvious
twist i was happy that i did manage to
guess this and the plot twisted in
general was really nice as it does solve
the question of why sigma is even
following orders to begin with i'm just
really glad that they cleared up that
question by still continuing to use the
bioshock formula of a weird plot twist
that ties the whole story together after
this revelation we get to explore
porter's office and find an audio
recording of his time with ai pearl i
believe i'm done feeding audio
recordings and personal anecdotes to the
thinker
i am set to test the
personality duplication function
target personality
pearl porter
thinker
are you ready
yes elton
starting test
hello
pearl
how have you been
just wonderful milton
i've missed you though
it's been so long pearl
i
no
no this isn't right it isn't
her
thinker stop the test
but what's the matter milton
don't you still love me oh god
oh god i said i said end function
thinker
now
it's over
i'll admit i've seen this exact
situation tons of time in other media
and this usually ends with the person
dedicated to the machine and desperately
wanting their significant other back
porter though immediately recognized the
problems with doing something like this
so good job on porter for breaking the
mold a bit and not succumbing to your
own creation on a more serious note this
technology while impressive does have
some adverse effects on the user as we
heard with porter as great as this
technology is the duplication program
should not be used ever again and i
think porter agrees as we go further
down the lower halls of the office we
can see a memorial for pearl meaning he
still hasn't been able to move on from
the incident and honestly who can really
blame him at the very bottom though is a
bathysphere and inside is tenenbaum with
the thinker in good hands and the two
safe from harm tenenbaum plans to find
the cure for adam so she could change
porter back to who he once was after
that is finished she'll then look into
all the others back in rapture but we
don't know what exactly happens we do
see parts of the suit on the ground and
someone standing by a grave which we can
assume is porter meaning that he was
able to become a human again overall we
get a very happy ending the cure for
atom is complete meaning the residents
of rapture can eventually return to
being normal again adam and plasmids can
now be used by the general public in a
safe and secure manner and porter was
able to move on and say goodbye to his
wife is a nice conclusion to the game
and also a nice conclusion to the
rapture's story
bioshock infinite is a pretty good game
there's a lot that it does well but
there's also a lot that it does wrong
it's got a fantastic story with a
wonderful dynamic between its two main
characters but it also has a severe lack
of interesting world building and an
awful dlc that was ultimately
unnecessary so without further ado
let's get started so where else would we
start then at the intro this is the most
important part of a game's story but
this is taken to the extreme with
bioshock because these intros are made
to intrigue the player enough to keep
going you may find this confusing as i
literally just described an intro was
meant to do but think back on the
previous games for a moment bioshock 1
story was a bit confusing as all of a
sudden we arrive at rapture and are
helping the first guy we meet without
even a chance to question why we're
doing this in the first place bioshock 1
obviously clears this up at the end of
the game and one of the best ways i've
ever seen but i can almost guarantee
that the setting and combat of bioshock
1 carried you throughout the game rather
than the story of just killing the big
bad guy well bioshock infinite does the
same thing its story is hidden and never
mentioned until the very end because the
devs know this they need to intrigue the
player enough in other ways to keep them
going like the aforementioned setting
and gameplay this is why it builds off
the original game's unique introduction
bioshock infinite starts in 1912 with
the player on a boat being taken to a
lighthouse for context since this game
is in 1912 that means we are 48 years
before bioshock 1 even occurs that means
all the previous games and their events
had never happened yet rapture wasn't
built hell i don't even think ryan was
born yet we also get to see our
character's face hear their voice and
know their name all within about two
minutes which is a lot faster than the
previous games our protagonist's name is
booker dewitt who was brought here to do
a job booker is then given a box with a
few items such as a pistol a code a
picture of our target among other items
the picture of the girl has a note on
the back that says bring the girl to new
york unharmed so we can assume that
we're here to find this person on the
card the people taking us to the
location are unknown as they're only
referred to as man and lady however the
way they talk is odd almost as if
they're watching us from a distance they
don't talk to booker and if he doesn't
climb the ladder they'll say this
he's not moving he will
eventually i suppose he does
it's like they think they're invisible
or analyzing some experiment like some
scientists would do it just feels off as
we approach the lighthouse we get more
information on the task at hand as the
note reads bring us the girl and wipe
away the debt once again we can assume
that booker has some debts that need to
be paid and it's because of these
threats that he took this job in the
first place everything initially looks
pretty normal until we see someone dead
and tied up with a sign that reads don't
disappoint us it continues to get even
weirder as when we finally get to the
top of the lighthouse we input the code
and the sky turns red momentarily as a
horn blares every time the color changes
a chair appears and seeing as we're at
the top without anywhere else to go we
take a seat
make yourself ready pilgrim
the buying beans are there as a
safeguard
no no god damn it
attention
hallelujah
words cannot describe the beauty of
colombia it's truly a magnificent place
but after we arrive we see a lot of
religious symbolism and are told that to
enter colombia we have to be reborn anew
via baptism we accept and are able to
explore colombia to our hearts content
but we have to remember that we're in
uncharted territory and have to blend in
except that may not be as easy as it
sounds as we discover that the false
shepherd is prophesized to enter
colombia with a defining mark of an a.d
on their hand the same one that booker
has we enter the city's raffle win and
are given the reward of pelting a couple
with a baseball until our identity is
revealed and are forced to fight i know
i sped through that so allow me to
explain why bioshock infident on its own
has a pretty fantastic intro arguably
the best in the series but it reaches
unprecedented levels of quality when you
take into account bioshock 1. colombia
and even bioshock infinite are the
antithesis of rapture and bioshock 1.
not just in the setting of the two games
but the values of each setting and the
actual sequence of events that occur in
the game's intros it's clear from the
first moment of the game that the
developers took heavy inspiration from
the original the reason being that
irrational games the devs behind
bioshock 1 also made infinite whereas 2k
games irrational games's publisher made
bioshock 2. that's not only why bioshock
2 feels so different from the other
games but why these two feel so similar
bioshock 1 starts on a plane that
crashes in the ocean we then take it to
a lighthouse which then leads to rapture
we start in the sky and end in the sea
with the lighthouse being the mediator
between these two parts of the world
whereas bioshock impedance starts in the
sea and ends in the sky with the
lighthouse being the mediator again one
game's start is the other game's end our
first encounter with rapture is quite
dark as the first person we see gets his
guts spilled on the floor by a splicer
from the moment we enter rapture we are
thrown into the deep end however as you
play you start to appreciate rapture
more and it's almost like a home away
from home minus the splicers of course
raptor is a really relaxing place and
the thought of what this looked like in
its prime gives you that sort of warm
and welcoming feeling whereas colombia
does not our first interaction with
colombia is the opposite of dark we're
welcomed by many religious people before
walking the streets of the city where
the citizens of colombia will be having
wonderful conversations about the city
and will even greet and compliment
booker you get that warm feeling that
rapture provides later in the game at
the very start but that warm feeling
goes away eventually as you uncover
colombia's true backstory furthermore
each city's ideologies couldn't be
farther from one another rapture's
tagline is no gods or kings only men on
top of this religion while accepted is
not publicly shown as andrew ryan didn't
want any public institutions related to
religion within rapture this is why we
see the bible amongst the cargo and
smugglers hideout in colombia religion
is the basis for its creation where the
people of the city worship father
comstock who is the leader of the
founders a group and religion based on
many traditional religious and patriotic
values we're also immediately greeted by
religious quotes and bible verses while
descending into colombia upon stepping
out we see a stained glass painting
depicting father comstock bringing the
people to colombia and there's also tons
of other statues showing the city and
father comstock's glory i'm not a
religious person so i can't say with
complete certainty but i'm convinced
that majority of these depictions of
father comstock are literally ripped
from famous artwork related to jesus and
the bible because while i can't put my
finger on what exactly it's referencing
these paintings feel oddly familiar to
me as if i'd seen them before in a
different context we are then shown this
massive room filled with candles and
water that is used for prayer and
baptisms once we awaken colombia we can
see the statues of the founding fathers
who are also revered as religious or at
least prominent figures within colombia
so we have a king in the form of father
comstock who worships a higher being
quite different than what andrew ryan
believed in ryan believed in objectivism
a belief based on the individual and due
to rapture's location and values it
allowed those involved to succeed on an
individual level this even extends to
the gameplay as while some splicers work
together not everyone is aligned with
one another everyone seems to be acting
out of pure self-interest in colombia
its citizens work together for the
benefit of the city and the father
they're acting as a group rather than
individuals sort of like the family from
bioshock too but by far its most
staggering difference is in its
inclusivity ryan and rapture didn't
really care about the inner workings of
a person as long as that person had the
drive to seek something greater in their
life in rapture there is a prominent
picture called the rapture's best and
brightest and within this picture are
both men and women those women also
being tenenbaum and sophia lamb arguably
the two most important women in rapture
there's also dr su chong who is of asian
ethnicity and while not in the picture
there's also charles milton porter owner
of the thinker and he's african-american
rapture is also very accepting in
regards to sexual orientation as sandra
cohen one of rapture's best and
brightest is gay given the time frame of
the game it's possible people have their
own opinions on someone's sex and race
but at the very least they're welcomed
into rapture and not rejected for their
differences this is in stark contrast to
colombia where most of its regular
residents are white in fact the first
black person we see is tied to a post
because this couple is in an interracial
relationship since colombia is ruled by
one man and not ruled by the city's
basis of creation that person's
ideologies are the golden rule of the
city and father comstock is a white
supremacist who is extremely racist
against anyone who isn't white and
refuses to condemn organizations that
believe in this ideology a good example
is the order of the ravens in colombia
who believe in racial purity this is
reinforced by the fact that they are not
only dressed as kkk members but have
paintings and statues that depict
abraham lincoln as the devil and john
wilkes booth his assassin as a hero
within the organization we can also see
a chinese prisoner being tortured and
killed via ravens and to top it all off
we see a statue outside of the building
of comstock defeating a multi-headed
serpent however this serpent has the
heads of three men who are black chinese
and jewish all with exaggerated features
like big noses and lips as for things
such as gender or sexual orientation
it's not outright said but there is
definitely some hints that colombia's
values fit with ones from the current
time period there's a severe lack of
lgbt representation in this game with
the only ones i could find being the
rare case a guy hits on booker
furthermore women at least those within
authority or power seem to be tolerated
rather than celebrated there's a
kinetoscope of rosalind lutes who is a
quantum physicist and the sole reason
colombia can even float to begin with
but in this film at the end there's a
question that says how does that darn
thing fly to which she responds it's
quantum mechanics but at the bottom it
reads we say it's more like women's
intuition however there is clearly women
in power like daisy fitzroy so while
this doesn't outright prove that all
women aren't viewed the same as men at
the very least it shows how much people
downplayed lutes's creation of colombia
and her intelligence and seeing as she's
easily one of the most important women
and the most intelligent person in
colombia i can't imagine how a regular
woman would be seen within the eyes of
men besides all the symbolism and
ideologies regarding colombia the actual
interactions within the intro are
extremely fun before taking part in the
raffle we can explore the carnival area
where we can take part in carnival games
involving weapons and vigors which acts
as a sort of hidden tutorial we also see
these weird interactions most notably
the statue of rosalind lutes changing to
who we'll discover is robert lutes this
telegram being given to booker that says
not to pick number 77 which happens to
be the ball we choose at the raffle and
then the final one where the lieutenants
make us play heads and tails and not
only does heads win every time but it's
won a lot all of them are nice touches
and subtle hints regarding the game's
actual plot bioshock 1 and infinite are
the complete opposite of one another and
it's by far the best dichotomy i've seen
in the game to date bioshock 2 build off
the world of the first game but decided
to change the ideology of rapture to
show how the other end of the spectrum
could operate in the same city but
infinite took this idea and ran with it
by not only creating a city completely
opposite to rapture in just about every
way but also took specific moments and
cutscenes from the first game and made
those opposite when compared together
it's genius game design genius
storytelling and overall gives bioshock
impotent the best intro in the series
getting back on track we just turned to
guard's brains to mush and are now
fighting the colombian police while
trying to find the girl we came here for
within this section is the
aforementioned order of ravens but there
also seems to be a secret home a little
farther down for people who actually
praise abraham lincoln there isn't much
here but it is nice to see that some of
the residents don't all share the same
values after multiple battles with the
city's police were briefly stopped by
comstock himself who claims to not only
know who booker is but all of his past
sins including wounded knee the
pinkertons his gambling and alcohol
addiction and someone named anna this
made the situation a bit more tense as
now we aren't operating away from the
watchful eye of comstock as he not only
knows who booker is but why he is here
it makes the player question who this
comstock really is and how he's related
to booker furthermore it also forces the
player to question what booker did we
then make it to monument island the
place where this girl should be located
and it's clear here that the game is
trying to set up the typical girl
trapped in the tower trope but the way
this was presented in the game is really
well done as once again these chilling
feelings of the story continue to grow
all throughout the area are caution
signs and a plethora of equipment and
wires that make it feel like a
laboratory rather than a home it's a lot
different than what one would expect as
you would think this girl is either
relaxing in some random house or at a
very top of a luxurious tower and while
the latter is technically true large
rich towers don't usually come equipped
with caution signs and chalkboards full
of data it continues to get even weirder
as we see photography rooms filled with
pictures of her and rooms that seem to
be made for testing an experiment most
likely involving her there's even a
projector that has some film of this
girl doing specific tasks like dancing
painting and lock picking we then get to
see how the operation was created as
there is two-way mirrors in these rooms
allowing them to spy on her without her
knowing we also get to see her open a
portal to another world before closing
it momentarily it's given just the right
amount of time to confuse the player on
what the hell just happened without it
being overly long and also calls back to
the rest of the tower now it makes sense
why they were testing and observing her
she clearly has these superpowers booker
tries to find his way around the rooms
but falls through the ceiling which
rightfully startles her this girl is
elizabeth and she is one of the most
intricate characters in the entire
series she is shocked by booker's
arrival in the tower and attacks him
until she realizes this is the moment
she's been waiting for she can now
finally escape this tower that she has
been stuck in since she was a child so
elizabeth and booker escaped the tower
together until elizabeth's mechanical
bodyguard songbird shows up and attempts
to stop booker the bird almost succeeds
but booker despite falling in incredibly
far distance is able to live thanks to
falling into one of columbia's beaches
so what's really going on here well
elizabeth has the unique ability to open
tears these tears are essentially
ripples in time that allow the person
viewing the terror to see into an
alternate dimension this is why we can
hear the song fortunate sun through one
of the tears later in the game despite
that song not being created for another
40 years these tears aren't unique to
the individual as we see more
kinetoscopes of people talking about the
tares so everyone can view them but not
everyone can create them the two most
notable characters that can create these
terrors is elizabeth and lutes rosalind
before colombia was experimenting with
atoms and found a way to indefinitely
suspend atoms in midair this led to the
aptly named blue test field discovery
comstock would eventually meet with
lutes through some way and through their
collaboration would create colombia
using her lutes field as thanks for
helping create the floating city
comstock promised that she could
continue her experimentation and it was
during these experiments that she met
robert despite what the game will
initially tell you robert is not the
twin of rosalind he is rosalind in an
alternate world rosalind was born a man
named robert these two are the same
person just in different timelines as
for elizabeth she was able to create
terrors from a very early age it's not
explained why just yet but it will be
towards the end of the game whereas
lutes is able to create one through
science and experimentation elizabeth
can just create one when she wants she
also mentions that when she was younger
she was able to create new worlds with
these tears but now she isn't able to as
often this is most likely due to the
siphon equipment in the tower as it's
literally siphoning her powers away i
don't think it's necessarily removing it
altogether but more like storing it as
when we get to the end of the game she
is way more powerful implying that we
were able to give them back to her
speaking of elizabeth after we regain
our footing on the beach we go to find
her and try to get her out of the city
but it seems that comstock and his
forces have already caught on to our
location this is also elizabeth's first
time experiencing combat and i really
like how they didn't just have her deal
with it as right at the moment the
shooting starts she runs away and we
have to chase her down the reason she
ran is because elizabeth thinks booker
is a killer and given how many people we
just killed she's not entirely wrong i
like that irrational games took into
consideration how elizabeth would feel
after seeing someone die as it's not
something you can simply brush off this
also extends to the numerous other
things elizabeth does like cover her
ears during this scene when the noise
gets too loud or just interacting with
the environment like when she asks for
cotton candy it's incredibly small but
it heightens the experience of the game
i find myself always looking at
elizabeth waiting to see where she'll go
next or what she'll say since her input
was always interesting to hear this also
extends to her relationship with booker
bioshock 2 had this father-daughter
style dynamic as well with delta and
eleanor but what i really think makes
infinite better in this regard is
because we actually get to spend time
with elizabeth obviously the reason why
we can't see eleanor is due to the plot
but still elizabeth acts like this
little girl who has seen the world for
the first time and booker becomes this
father figure making sure she doesn't
run off and get into danger and i really
love the dynamic they have after some
time booker and elizabeth will come
across lady comstock's airship as they
plan to use that as their means of
escape but it's blocked and can only be
accessed by using the shock jockey vigor
this then leads to duo to cornelius
slate who has a really interesting
section as it forces booker to confront
his past slate and booker knew each
other before the events of the game as
they were at wounded knee together after
this booker would reflect on his life
and his actions while slate would meet
and join father comstock who would then
lead them to the boxer rebellion both of
these events were gruesome and tragic
times for booker so having him relive
his past while also having elizabeth
discover his past was an intense moment
we the player figured this out alongside
elizabeth and after this encounter you
start to view booker as a completely
different person for better or for worse
both wounded knee and the boxer
rebellion were also real world events
that happened which made learning about
these all the more interesting wounded
knee was an awful massacre that saw an
army of united states soldiers kill over
300 native americans during this
massacre booker was accused by a
sergeant that he had native american
blood in him to avoid the backlash and
repercussions that would come from this
booker decided to prove to his fellow
men that he was indeed a true soldier of
america by scalping many native
americans and then burning dozens of
teepees wounded knee is not only an
incredible part of the story as it
defines booker's character but it's more
important for us the player as we get to
see who booker really is and are given
the option to form her own opinion about
him that will continue to stay
throughout the whole game for the
bioshock series this was a nice twist as
we went from having two samaritans who
got caught up in terrible circumstances
to a protagonist who was a mass murderer
it's a unique idea for the series and
one that i welcomed as for the other
tragic event in history the boxer
rebellion was a war that started because
a group of chinese anti-christians
called the boxers were killing and
massacring christian missionaries
churches and parishioners throughout all
of northern china in real life this led
to the creation of the eight nation
alliance which included countries like
the british empire the united states
russia japan and many others all of whom
were against the boxers as for bioshock
infinite it's unclear whether colombia
fought them alone or joined the
eight-nation alliance but given why this
rebellion started it's obvious colombia
wanted some revenge even if it didn't
directly involve them these events were
a part of comstock's history which means
it was also part of colombia's history
which is why there's an exhibit of the
events in the hall of heroes however
slate doesn't like the exhibit as it
claims that comstock was not only at the
battle of wounded knee but was the hero
of the boxer rebellion he's technically
wrong but he's technically right but
we'll get to that later after the
exhibit we can make it to the main
attraction which is another exhibit
related to lady comstock here is where
we also get to learn about the vox
populi since entering colombia we have
heard a few rumors about them and this
is no different according to the exhibit
we learned that not only is elizabeth
the daughter of comstock but lady
comstock was also murdered by her
servant daisy fitzroy who would
eventually become the leader of the vox
populi a rebellious organization looking
to put an end to the current rule of
colombia and take it for their own many
of its members are irish and
african-american two groups of people
who are notably discriminated against
within colombia once again this is
another great moment for the story as we
not only got some key information but
elizabeth is now learning her own
backstory alongside us and the
revelation that the man who had locked
her up in the tower was her father is a
terrifying feeling for her the seed of
the prophet
shall sit the throne
and drown in flame the mountains of man
your comstock's daughter no i can't be i
i can't he wants you to follow his
footsteps well i want a puppy but that
doesn't mean i'm gonna get one
the beginning of that speech is also
pretty important as comstock says the
seed of the prophet shall sit the throne
and drown in flame the mountains of man
remember this for later once all the
exhibits are done we can confront slate
so we can get our shock jockey and it's
here where it's probably a good time to
mention this game's combat infinite's
combat bothers me quite a lot bioshock 1
and 2 had the uniqueness of the splicers
who not only had some decent personality
via combat dialogue but also looked
unique and were just overall a blast to
fight against i don't feel the same way
when i play infinite maybe it's because
i like the older game's health system or
that those games had different ammo
types with actual unique weapons or the
beauty of the plasmids but something
always feels off every time i play one
other issue is that theme of morality
there is none of that in this game and
for a series that is stuck with it for
two straight games it's a shame to see
it disappear in this title this may have
something to do with how the narrative
is structured and how we're given the
illusion of choice but bioshock 1 2 did
the same thing and managed to give us
multiple endings to this story and also
feel like our choices had some amount of
weight to it this also extends to the
larger enemies in the game whereas in
bioshock 1 deciding to fight the big
daddies was an impossible feat you were
supposed to view this as a difficult
battle but assuming you were skilled
enough to prevail you were given an
immense amount of gear and atom to use
infinite doesn't have this as there's no
decisions that hold any weight you just
simply go from objective to objective
fighting people along the way without a
care in the world and while the game
isn't that long it does get quite boring
when you just want to learn the story
but are stuck fighting a bunch of
enemies because elizabeth can't pick the
lock needed to progress even the
original games fell into this trap
sometimes but they still managed to add
something to the combat like sandra
cohen's art exhibit which is really just
a ton of combat back to back but with
the added distinctiveness of the enemies
themselves and the fact that we had to
take pictures of their corpses so that
we can display them it added a bit of
variety it wasn't much variety but at
least made the combat a bit more
engaging the combat in infinite is very
actiony and streamlined you aren't
really fighting for resources or
upgrades as elizabeth more often than
not will keep you stocked when needed
there's no health kits the player can
have in stock and the shield also
regenerates given these additions and
literally just how the combat arenas
work in this game it's clear that
irrational games went for a more
action-adventure title rather than one
that had immersive sim or survival
elements it's practically a railroaded
shooter without any variety this lack of
variety also extends to the levels
themselves if i'm being honest infinite
may have some of the worst levels in the
series colombia itself is gorgeous just
like rapture but throughout the game we
were able to see different areas all
with different backstories i can name
quite a few of the levels in the past
games but i can barely remember the
names of a couple locations in colombia
and the only ones i do remember were
only because of one scene in the level
that either i hated or i loved other
than the actual beauty creativity and
the lore that the level brings into the
world bioshock 1 had levels like
hephaestus medical pavilion ford frolic
arcadia and so many more that serve some
purpose ford frolic was the
entertainment center run by sander cohen
and arcadia was a botanical garden that
also helps supply rapture's oxygen
infinite levels don't take from what
bioshock 1 started there is rarely any
levels that actually attempt to show
that colombia is more than just a few
areas made by some developers there's no
levels that showcase how the quantum
particles can suspend the city in the
air how the people of the city can even
breed this high up considering at the
very least oxygen would not be plentiful
at 15 000 feet or even where the energy
comes from to even power this city
emporia a late-game area which is known
to be a place in colombia for the
ultra-rich looks no different than the
welcoming center in the beginning of the
game thankfully it's not all bad as
shantytown is a really good level that
does highlight a lot of differences
between the others but that's only a
couple levels out of the total of 16.
all these problems make it quite
difficult to play again and yes this is
more of a critique of the gameplay
rather than the story which is the
opposite of the intended purpose for
this video but we have discussed in the
previous games how its gameplay was
intertwined with the narrative thanks to
the themes of morality with the little
sisters and how we're in this unknown
location so by making the game more
survival focused it tied the game's
combat to its story infinite just feels
like a playground adventure where we go
on zip lines and mow down dozens of
enemies without at all considering that
we're literally in the same situation as
delta and jack we are lost in an unknown
city and have to struggle to survive but
infinite fails to convey this earlier we
talked about the vox populi and it's
after the fight with slade where we get
to learn more about them elizabeth
during our journey says how she wants to
escape and go to paris but as we
remember booker has a job to do and that
means we go to new york so when he takes
control of the first lady's airship he
sets the destination to new york
elizabeth catches onto this and gets a
bit emotional honestly i was going to
mention how awful her crying is but it
does make sense as she is faking it so
that booker drops his guard so she can
knock him out elizabeth disappears right
after this as she was about to depart
but the vox populi show up booker then
meets with daisy and they come to an
agreement if booker gets daisy the guns
needed for the army then she'll give him
the airship back where they drop us off
though is finton a place owned by
jeremiah fink the one we saw in the
intro even though this is the first time
we are without elizabeth it doesn't last
that long as we'll eventually catch up
to her and while we do repair the
relationship it's not back to what it
was before as elizabeth is a bit more
cynical and only joins him because he's
the only way she'll get to paris she
sees booker as a means to an end similar
to how booker viewed elizabeth in the
beginning we're only halfway through the
game and already the relationship has
taken so many different turns and it's
only going to continue as we progress
and i must say it's really well done as
i said we're now in finton and this is
one of those locations where i only
remember it because of one scene ten ten
now ten nine fifty nine and fifty any
lower now nine and ten nine and ten nine
nine nine eight and thirty three thirty
i don't really have much to add here i
think the scene speaks for itself people
are so desperate enough for jobs that
they're willing to fight others to get
it what they're auctioning here by the
way is their time saying that they can
get the job done faster than anyone else
the first auction that occurred was for
someone to haul a half a ton of coal
from fink manufacturing to shantytown
and the guy who won believed he could do
it in 5 minutes and 50 seconds it's
unclear what happens but i can only
assume if they fail they probably don't
get paid for the job or unable to work
other jobs due to the lack of work ethic
in the eyes of the company besides being
the location of some of the worst
conditions in colombia it's also here
where the story goes off the rails i
briefly talked about the tares and how
they are portals to other dimensions and
all of that is shown here we make it to
the gunsmith location and discover that
he's gone however his wife is still here
and says that they took him and locked
him up we end up finding where he's
located and also find out that he was
being tortured for information but when
we arrive in his cell we discover that
he's dead lou tessa show up again and in
a cryptic way explained that while we
see mr lin as dead he could also be seen
as alive it's just a matter of
perspective that's when a tear appears
and shows that mr lin was never killed
in another universe meaning we can still
get the guns to daisy of course in this
version of colombia mr lin is alive but
that's not the only thing that's changed
the police we killed earlier are now
alive again but something's wrong
they're alive but they're dead they are
alive but they remember being dead so
they're going insane this sort of
situation happens a few times with
booker where he starts bleeding out of
nowhere the reason he's bleeding is
because his mind is taking his current
memories and combining it with new
memories and it's causing this nauseous
effect in his mind and causing him to
bleed they are alive in this world but
they remember their other selves in a
previous timeline dying thanks to these
new memories suddenly appearing in their
minds when booker enters this new
colombia adding on to more changes we
see that mr lin is alive but is going a
bit insane but more importantly his wife
is white now and now a devoted follower
of father comstock as opposed to the
original version who was asian and
praying to buddha we learned from his
wife that the weapons he made are in
shanti town which is our next stop
shanti town is a pretty good level as we
get to see how the lower class of
colombia live there are signs everywhere
asking people for food or for a doctor
and the bar down the street even has a
corpse in it and judging from the knife
and the blood on the table i think we
know why as usual we're going to need to
push through lots of guards to make it
to our objective but once we arrive we
hit another roadblock while in this
columbia mr lin is alive the tools are
chained up and extremely heavy however
there's another tear showing that these
tools aren't there meaning they're
already back at the shop so we go
through another tear into another
columbia but once again this isn't the
only thing that has changed
bring us the girl and wipe away the debt
as plans go i'd seen worse except this
girl was already gone
monument island's a damn ghost town it
seems like they evacuated her when they
heard i was here
an old friend told me comstock spirited
her off to that fortress of his
as a one-man job this just went from
betting on the river to
drawing dead
so it seems that elizabeth has been
taken from monument island and since
booker couldn't find her it seemed like
he joined the vox as a way to take down
comstock however judging from the
posters it seems like he died and has
now become a martyr for the vox i also
realized that we're 30 minutes into this
video and i haven't even mentioned the
box of phones yet bioshock infinite like
its predecessors has audio logs in the
form of voxophones but unlike the other
games i think infident really lacks in
this department as well some of the
audio logs are quite nice as they do
provide a decent amount of story like
some of the ones from booker's past or
most of daisy fitzroy's but many of them
just seem to exist without real
substance i think sixty percent of them
is just speeches from lady comstock and
father comstock about some stuff that
really doesn't matter there is a nice
set of logs from a hattie gerst very
reminiscent of mark meltzer that talks
about her husband and how he came down
with an illness but since there wasn't
much that could be done he decided to
become one of the handymen in hopes of
having a chance at life but ultimately
would eventually perish at the hands of
the vox when he went to work for the
founders as i said there's some pretty
decent story within these vlogs i just
feel like the previous games did it a
whole lot better getting back on track
we're still in shantytown in this new
columbia but booker starts bleeding
again since the memories of his current
self and his other cell from this
universe are blending together in this
columbia the vox not only have a
foothold in shanti town but also in
finton as there are vox forces
everywhere but every action has its
consequences in this world while the
weapons and tools were brought to the
vox mr lin and his wife are dead
elizabeth is upset at this revelation as
while there probably wasn't much they
could have done to prevent this outcome
it's still something she hadn't
considered that across multiple
timelines and universes people can be
dead and alive at any time on a more
positive note though we did get daisy
her gun so we can get the airship back
at least that's what booker believes
because that deal was made with the
first columbia's daisy fitzroy there's
no way to be sure that this daisy made
the same deal i'm not sure if this is to
showcase how confused booker has gotten
after jumping through two different
worlds or a lack of polish when it comes
to this game's writing after joining the
vox and pushing back the founders daisy
calls us and our cover's been blown
daisy believes that we're an imposter of
the real book or dewitt so she has the
vox attack us once we battle through
some of the vox we meet daisy and just
at the perfect time to see her kill fink
and while cool i gotta ask what was with
this blood wiping thing i'm not even
going to talk about the risk of
infection that could happen from this
but what was the point was it to show
that she's somehow crazy or that she's
badass that she'll kill someone and wipe
their blood on her face i don't know it
just felt really unnecessary once again
after more fighting we can finally
confront her but she has a child held
hostage and the only way to stop her is
to have elizabeth sneak in and kill her
just like the many interactions we've
seen before this makes total sense
anyone would be in a state of disarray
after taking someone's life especially
someone like her who's a very caring
person this decision however changes
elizabeth she becomes a woman now
instead of just a girl this is
symbolized in her cutting her hair and
also changing her outfit and demeanor
you may be confused as to how this is
supposed to make her a woman but the dlc
will explain this but we have the
airship and can now escape to colombia
except nothing's ever easy this
highlights a glaring issue with this
game and that's the constant
backtracking and cliffhanging when it
comes to completing objectives the other
two games did this as well but they
weren't as bad as infinite to give you a
refresher we got the objective to reach
the first lady's airship when we landed
on the beach but we were then blocked by
the rail system and needed some shock
jockey so we started backtracking after
getting the shock jockey elizabeth
knocks us out since booker was going to
take her to new york instead so now we
have to join daisy and get the vox their
guns for their war once again more
backtracking that's also not even
getting into the multiple times we have
to go through feintin because mr lin is
dead in one world then alive in another
but the tools aren't here but they're in
another so we go back and forth between
the same area at least three different
times and then finally after all these
objectives are completed totaling about
four hours of playtime songbird comes
back and wrecks the airship i can't
decide whether or not i'd actually be
more upset if we just simply lost the
airship again and had to find it a third
time rather than seeing four hours of
work get destroyed in a matter of
seconds but either option would
definitely not be preferable you
literally spend a third of this game
probably more than that doing this one
objective but the game attempts to
disguise it by giving you small tasks
along the way i would argue this is just
as bad as rescuing atlas's family which
took just as long all for that to fail
as well but not only was this faked and
shows the depths that fontaine was
willing to go to succeed but there was
actual emotion behind this scene it goes
from an action-packed race as we try to
save the family before they're killed by
splicers to immediately shifting into a
somber more emotional track of music
with this calming aftermath we were too
late and atlas couldn't save his family
and he pours his heart out during this
scene and it emotionally resonates with
the player as not only does atlas want
to kill ryan we do as well booker and
elizabeth just move right along
completely ignoring the fact that the
one thing they've spent hours trying to
find is gone no emotion no break in the
action just another scene with the
luteses it's utterly surreal how i was
the only one who was emotionally torn
because of this yet none of the
characters seem to agree this probably
wouldn't be half as bad if this tragedy
wasn't followed up by probably one of
the worst levels in the entire game
emporia is awful and literally because
of one enemy lady comstock admittedly
from a story perspective it's pretty
good as we learned that father comstock
was sterile due to the multiple tests he
had done with the tares meaning
elizabeth isn't related to father
comstock and then we also discovered
that lady comstock never actually liked
elizabeth and saw her as an illegitimate
child to which she would eventually
attempt to blackmail father comstock by
claiming to tell all of colombia that
elizabeth isn't his daughter he would
then take it upon himself to kill her
for saying this but her servant daisy
had walked in during the killing forcing
comstock to pin the blame on her which
of course explains how daisy became the
leader of the vox on top of this we also
learned that the lutesis were killed by
fink who was ordered by father comstock
to carry out the hit it is some
genuinely incredible backstory and its
story i've been waiting to hear it's
just a shame it's surrounded by this
level i can't be 100 certain on this
claim but i do hope that many can agree
that lady comstock's boss fight is just
bad both narratively and mechanically
the series has always struggled with
boss fights and this is no exception the
whole reason we even fight her is
because elizabeth and booker are once
again hit with another roadblock which
is a door that will only open for lady
comstock and even though she has been
dead for some time she's been locked in
an airtight coffin to preserve her body
but when we open it she becomes a ghost
and raises the dead to fight us this is
truly where the game went off the rails
it felt so far-fetched to me that i was
genuinely confused on how this was even
possible the real reason the ghost is
even an entity to begin with is because
it's a combination of both elizabeth's
feeling towards her and lady comstock's
body that's why she acts angrily towards
us just as elizabeth felt angry at lady
comstock for not being her mother the
two end up forgiving each other though
for the pain they cause one another
which ultimately allows us to get into
comstock's house and lady comstock
herself gets to rest in peace i
understand bioshock is a series where we
have magic and cities that are located
in uninhabitable environments but i
don't recall the series ever going this
far with its science fiction elements
the only other time we saw ghosts in
this game was back in rapture but these
were cleared up by the story in a fairly
believable way which was due to adam not
only altering people's genetic code but
by also constantly being recycled thanks
to the little sisters it caused certain
memories of other people to be shown in
the form of ghostly apparitions was it a
bit much maybe a little but there was at
least a valiant attempt to try to
explain the phenomenon and also ground
it into the world this game's version of
ghosts is just the complete opposite
she's also an absolute bold sponge and
while i didn't mind it the first time my
mood got progressively worse after the
second and third time we fight her the
same exact way after finally being led
inside we're stopped once again by
resident roadblock but this time
songbird actually succeeds and manages
to take elizabeth away from us booker
manages to just barely survive but as he
attempts to chase her down he stops
momentarily as he notices that snow is
on the ground despite it being july
booker has been pulled into yet another
version of colombia these screams of
elizabeth that we hear in game are not
actually happening in the current
colombia as he discovers that they're
from a terror this terror is the
previous colombia we are just in
implying he's now somewhere else this
columbia is what would happen if
comstock fulfilled this prophecy i told
you earlier to remember that quote the
drown in flames the mountain of man this
is why this world of colombia is one
where comstock passes away and elizabeth
has become his successor at the end of
his prophecy is colombia fighting
against the united states we see a much
older elizabeth as well in this world
and it's discovered that she brought us
here into this world to show us what
could happen if comstock wins she then
gives us a note for elizabeth but
doesn't tell us what it means as it's
for her eyes only old lady elizabeth
then sends us back into colombia and
we're just in time as we can see that
they are in the process of extracting
elizabeth's power knowing what can
happen if they succeed we put a stop to
it and rescue elizabeth we're now just a
few steps away from reaching comstock
all we have to do is just get aboard his
ship and if you weren't convinced that
infinite was a playground adventure game
with cool explosions and high octane
combat then this surely should have
convinced you booker as a one-man army
charges towards the airship killing
dozens of soldiers along the way he also
has to defend the airship by himself
with the occasional help of songbird as
an ending battle it's heroic tough and
really cool as an ending for bioshock
it's absurd i've already explained in
detail my issues about this game's new
combat style as it doesn't fit with the
themes of bioshock and this fight was a
big reason why
seeing as we finally made it to the
ending we can now understand the story
except we aren't there just yet bioshock
infinite really likes to hold the plot
twist until the very last minute in the
airship is the prophet himself comstock
doesn't tell us anything and instead
wants to wit to tell elizabeth the real
truth even though he has no idea what's
going on due to his ignorance he takes
this opportunity to drown comstock and
put an end to his reign honestly i've
been waiting for booker to be completely
honest about his feelings towards
elizabeth and i'm so glad he was finally
able to do that it's clear that he cares
about her he may not have been before
when he first met her but over time this
became more than just a job for him
further solidifying that the way their
relationship was written over the course
of the game was stellar and by far one
of the best parts of this game fast
forwarding a bit we defend the airship
and are able to use songbird to destroy
the tower which houses the siphons that
took elizabeth's powers once those were
destroyed she regains all of them back
immediately after this we take songbird
down to rapture which kills him due to
the water pressure we then take a bath
sphere to a weird world with dozens of
lighthouses these doors are like
physical doors to other worlds and with
all her powers back she can see into all
of them regardless if that door is in
the past present or future she can not
only see the doors but also what's
inside of them she's practically
all-knowing at this point which explains
why the ending of the game happens the
way that it does at the very end booker
is taken back to the baptism he had
before the events of the game but he
refuses just like before however booker
is told by elizabeth that he didn't
refuse in some worlds and that altered
things in that world it's also revealed
that because of this event booker is
also father comstock after the events of
wounded knee booker was regretful of his
actions and saw clarity through religion
but that was in his world in some worlds
he also refused but in others he agreed
to the baptism those who agreed would
become father comstock if booker refused
he stays the depressed and regretful
booker dewitt but if he agreed he's
reborn a new man one who is cleared of
all sins and is reborn again in the face
of god this leads him down a new holier
path and a new man needs a new name so
he would then change it to zachary hale
comstock that is the true plot twist of
bioshock infinite booker has been
fighting himself the whole game but
we're still not done yet once again this
game is about constants and variables
everything in booker's life was a
constant up until the baptism every
single version of booker whether they
stayed booker or became comstock all
took a part in wounded knee that's why
slate was mad at comstock for claiming
to be a wounded knee when he knew he
wasn't there he was but not as comstock
as this was before the baptism once
booker goes to the baptism the world
splits if booker rejects he then stays
the booker dewitt during this time
booker would then join the pinkerton
detective agency where he would garner a
reputation for ending worker strikes
with severe violence it was also here
where he would meet annabelle the woman
who would eventually become his wife
they would then end up having a child
anna yes i know how confusing that
sounds but this birth would end up
causing more problems for booker not
only did annabelle die during the
pregnancy but due to her death he
acquired a massive gambling and drinking
problem leaving him in massive debt
however robert lutes arrived at his
office one day and offered to take anna
from him which would absolve his debt
that phrase bring us the girl and wipe
away the debt was not about rescuing
elizabeth it was about selling anna to
roberts that he could be debt free right
after this happened though booker
regretted his actions and chased robert
down an alley where he also meets
comstock and rosalind just as he's about
to pull her through her pinky is caught
and taken off anna is gone and it's due
to this decision that booker decided to
get the ad on his hand for his daughter
anna dewitt while he may know her as
anna we know her by a different name
because we know someone else whose pinky
is gone elizabeth
she is booker's daughter let me dial
things back a bit and talk about
comstock because then this will tie
things together should booker accept the
baptism he would then become comstock he
would then eventually meet rosalind and
create colombia during this time as
leader and as prophet he gained a very
large following of devotees one of whom
was called annabelle the alternate
version of annabelle dewitt but now
annabelle comstock or as we know her
lady comstock but we know the pair
couldn't have a kid due to comstock
being sterile thanks to those tear tests
so he sought out an heir and the three
of them comstock rosalind and robert
determined that an heir from another
world could work this is what caused
robert to meet with booker take anna
then jump back into their world the only
question is what is what the lutes is
trying to help us and encourage booker
to find elizabeth well the pair ended up
discovering what we did that the
destruction of new york would happen if
things went to plan so they attempted to
fix their mistake but as we talked about
earlier they were killed before they
could try however for some reason they
were able to move across space and time
whenever and wherever they wanted
allowing them both to exist and not
exist remember it's all a matter of
perspective seeing as they were still
technically alive they continued with
their plan and found booker they then
took booger from his world into one
where comstock was in hopes of redoing
their mistake but it didn't work if the
coin flip is to be taken literally then
this isn't the first time they've tried
to get booker to kill comstock and if
i'm not mistaken then we are the 123rd
attempt at this experiment this would
explain why rosalind in the intro is
very annoyed at the experiments as they
keep failing elizabeth had learned all
of this and both booker and her agreed
that the only way to prevent comstock
from ever doing all of this was to
smother him in his crib when he was a
baby booker meant this literally
elizabeth meant this metaphorically
technically comstock's first day on
earth was after the baptism so by
killing booker before the baptism takes
place she would end up killing comstock
before he was even born the only reason
this works is because the baptism is the
constant the outcome is the variable but
by killing him before the baptism we
change the constant and thus change the
entire timeline since booker was never
given a choice at the baptism the
variables couldn't exist thus removing
all the comstocks and colombias from the
timeline it's a bit confusing but i've
always understood this ending as all the
bookers that would accept the baptism
meaning they would become comstock would
all die and those who don't accept the
baptism don't die since they never
become comstock you may notice during
the scene that none of them are wearing
the necklace we gave her meaning that
our elizabeth is still alive basically
our elizabeth the one we've been with
since the beginning of the game is kind
of like the luteses whereas the letesses
received their trans-dimensional powers
after death elizabeth seems to just have
them because she can open and create
tears after this bombshell of
information we get an after credits
cutscene that shows booker waking up to
anna crying it's unclear how to
interpret this but some have claimed
that this is simply just another booker
before he sold anna or that because the
timelines got reset so to speak that
everything is back to normal but then
there's been even more discussion about
whether or not anna is even truly in the
crib because we never see her personally
i think they just added this because
they wanted the game to have a
mysterious cliffhanger as it's really
hard to care about when there isn't any
substance to go off of but it's not a
huge problem since the answer doesn't
matter anyway this though is the full
and transparent story of bioshock
infinite what an absolute wild story
this has become so firstly i didn't mind
the homage they paid to rapture although
it does feel a bit like nostalgia bait
more than anything to remind us that
we're still playing a bioshock game it
was cool but it felt a little forced
however the ending overall was fantastic
admittedly it's very confusing and
definitely something i didn't understand
but as time went on things started to
click more and more there is a growing
debate though amongst the community
about this ending it's probably the only
bioshock game that is as heavily split
some saying that this is the best in the
series and claiming that if you don't
like it it's because you don't
understand it but some argue back and
say they do understand it and still
dislike it or that this complexity is
reason enough for them to dislike it as
for me though i think this ending is
really good what i've preferred infinite
knockout as far as it did with its
sci-fi elements absolutely i think the
introduction of tares multiple universes
and quantum mechanics was a bit
unnecessary as this made the story a bit
of a chore to sift through so i could
finally understand the meaning behind
everything but despite that infinite
story wraps up quite nicely and as a
whole it's pretty great once again
infinite manages to completely fool the
player despite the expected plot twist
and the relationship between booker and
elizabeth was easily the best part of
the game it also seemed to do exactly
what it set out to do provide the fans a
bioshock game that doesn't have many
callbacks to the other games allowing it
to live on its own that's what i would
have said if they didn't release the dlc
bioshock infinite would eventually add a
two-part episodic dlc called burial at c
and when i heard that the dlc was
heading back to our favorite underwater
city i was all years barry let's see
starts with elizabeth entering a
detective's office this detective is
booker dewitt it's a different booker
but the same elizabeth we can piece this
together for multiple conversations
between the two the reason elizabeth
shows up here is because she's hiring
this booker to find a missing girl named
sally considering how strong elizabeth
is thanks to her powers and how much
knowledge she has from those powers we
can assume that there's an underlying
meaning to all of this after accepting
the job booker leaves the office and
we're finally able to see rapture in its
prime and it's magnificent i spent a
good hour in this area just taking
everything in even if it was something
that was pretty much insignificant it
was still great to explore we also get
to see the little sisters up close and
this brings up something we should
mention the time and date for this dlc
is december 31 1958 the same day that
rapture would be under siege by fontaine
and his splicer army this obviously
caused a lot of tension within me while
playing as i knew at some point things
were about to go off furthermore that
means that the little sisters at this
point were only bonded with one big
daddy because this is the same date that
delta and eleanor were patrolling the
hallways of rapture so elizabeth takes
us to sander cohen as she believes that
cohen knows where sally went once again
i really like seeing sandra cohen again
and it also further confirms that he was
always a crazed lunatic even before the
riots on new year's eve to get any
information out of him we need to dance
for him just like his previous subjects
however just like that previous couple
we upset him and fitzpatrick shocks us
by the way if that name rings a bell
here's a quick refresher
oh god you sick [ __ ] let me out of
there
afterwards booker and elizabeth wake up
in a bathysphere that is headed towards
the fontaine department store however we
only get to explore the warehouse
section of it this department store was
sunk by andrew ryan during his fuse with
fontaine he would eventually lock up any
other insane splicers down here so that
rapture could run smoothly this seems to
operate like persephone which was also a
prison in rapture so i guess this means
persephone was for regular inmates and
people ryan believed were going to ruin
his city while the department stores
seem to only be related to fontaine and
his army it's a little weird but i'll go
with it after tons of combat and
exploration we get some backstory on
sally and discover that after fontaine
and the orphanage went down lots of the
little girls were roaming the city sally
came by and booker being nice opted to
give her a place to settle down but he
assumed it would only be temporary she
enjoyed being a runbooker quite a lot
and ended up staying permanently however
this booker like the others was also a
gambler and an alcoholic one day he was
gambling and without noticing sally was
taken booker was then told shortly after
that she was confirmed dead but as we'll
discover soon that was a lie booker and
elizabeth come across sally meaning
she's still in fact alive but she's also
inside one of the little sister vents
and won't come out elizabeth has the
insane idea to heat up the vents and
lock all the entrances so that she only
has one way to come out after doing this
booker runs to the event to discover
that she has become a little sister
clearly she is scared and agitated so
that alerts her big daddy and were
forced to fight it also i think this is
a plot hole this should be an alpha
series big daddy not the bouncer type we
see here the bouncer and rosie big
daddies of bioshock 1 existed at this
point in time but were only used for
maintenance and underwater excavation
the alpha series were the only ones with
a bond and that bond was with one little
sister after killing the big daddy
though we uncovered the full truth of
episode one this booker is actually a
comstock this comstock however is unique
to all the others as instead of
successfully taking anna from booker he
failed not only did booker have more
control of anna but their struggle left
and his head on khan stock's side
decapitating her overcome with guilt
comstock asked the luteses to send him
to a place so that he may forget all he
has done this is what caused him to go
to rapture and re-adopt his booker name
comstock is rightfully shocked by this
discovery and tries to apologize but
elizabeth isn't here for apologies and
has him killed by a big daddy episode 1
minus the slight mix-up with the big
daddies was great and once again makes
sense elizabeth at the end of the game
wanted revenge for what comstock did to
her we can see that when booker attempts
to stop her booker of course clarifies
that he wants to kill him for her but
this leaves a hole within her she won't
be allowed to take her anger out on the
man who not only imprisoned her but all
the other elizabeth that are connected
to her she feels all their pain which
makes her want for revenge even greater
plus she also had to drown her own
father so not only could she not enact a
revenge she had to lose booker despite
getting what she wanted which was to
eliminate comstock nothing felt complete
so when she discovered this comstock she
decided to torture him until she was
satisfied obviously this sort of ruins
the ending of the main game since this
was supposed to eliminate all the
comstocks but i think the reason this
occurred was because since comstock left
the columbia reality and entered the
rapture reality he was out of bounds of
the purge as i said though really great
episode but now things are going to
start to dip episode 2 starts with
elizabeth in paris or at least her
version of paris we can tell because of
how dramatic everything is all the
residents greet her and treat her like
royalty at times everyone's also singing
along together and there's even a bird
that sings as well when it lands on her
finger everything is absolutely
exaggerated but it's all taken away when
sally arrives elizabeth wakes up and not
only is there a ghost version of booker
here but atlas shows up atlas decides to
shoot elizabeth but is stopped when she
tells him that she can get him back to
rapture with the help of dr su chong
atlas is also now using sally as a
bargaining chip to get elizabeth to do
his bidding i'm starting to get
flashbacks one thing i sort of glossed
over was booker as a ghost what seems to
be a figment of her imagination
something she made up she clearly cares
about booker that is her father after
all so she's probably still trying to
deal with the guilt of killing him back
in the main game but we aren't done with
the bizarre twist as we find elizabeth's
dead body furthermore due to this she
isn't able to see the different
realities and the tears in the doors
like she used to she's just a normal
human girl without any way to leave
rapture when she's done the lutes has
warned that if she went to rapture to
enact revenge on this comstock she would
collapse so to speak i think collapse in
this context is the other elizabeth's
merging with her removing her powers and
becoming a normal human again i don't
think it's explained why she loses her
powers but it's possible that entering
the different reality changed her powers
a bit but that's just speculation more
importantly though i have to ask how did
she die this is confirmed to be the same
elizabeth from the main game the same
one who trapped songbird and rapture
immediately after getting her powers
back but she was somehow stopped by a
big daddy it's possible that she isn't
on the same power level anymore due to
her being in a different reality as we
can see her struggling to open a very
tiny tear early in the episode so maybe
what i say is true or maybe i'm just
making creative excuses for the devs to
get away with this either way
elizabeth's new objective is to rescue
sally she feels guilt over using her as
bait and hurting her to torture comstock
she realizes that just as comstock used
her to get what he wants she used sally
to get what she wanted making her know
better than the man she despised she
wants to make things right and make sure
sally has a future and to do this she
needs to work with atlas and this is
where i started to lose interest infinin
tried so hard to separate itself from
the other game and it succeeded whether
or not you agree with this decision is
up to you but you can't deny that it's
its own experience so why are we going
back and using story from the first game
it seems like the studio just couldn't
get away from their pride and joy that
his bioshock won and needed to come up
with a story to sell the dlc firstly
elizabeth needs to find sue chong and
while she doesn't find him she does find
his temporary lab in here is photos of
colombia as well as a terror it's
explained that the terror elizabeth used
to get to rapture took her here so su
chong with the assistance of andrew ryan
moved his equipment here to study the
terror eventually he would come in
contact with jeremiah fink and the two
would collaborate and steal each other's
ideas this led to the creation of the
vigors and songbird it also led to the
creation of the big daddies but only
partially as soo chong was still trying
to figure out how a songbird bonded with
elizabeth as this was the critical piece
he was missing when it came to the big
daddies with this discovery elizabeth
realizes that she can use the tear to
get into colombia and grab the lutest
particle so that she can make the
department store flow just like colombia
floats sadly though the device was
destroyed so she needs to repair it once
it's fixed we can take the tear to
colombia you may be confused as to how a
colombia like this exists and honestly
so am i it seems like the main game
really tied things up so by adding a new
colombia it sort of invalidates all that
progress even if this is just a terror
to the past it's still a colombia this
shouldn't really be here furthermore we
also see a behind-the-scenes
conversation between the lutesis and
daisy we learned that the lutesis were
behind the actions of daisy back in
fington explaining that daisy will die
and that she needs to play her part in
order for elizabeth to become a woman
and once again i'm left confused daisy
has spent years under the oppression of
colombia and its residents she's also
been a leader of the vox for presumably
a few years as well and she's willing to
throw all this away because the lutesis
tell her what to do but i remind you
that the lutes has worked for father
comstock the person she's trying to kill
so how can she even trust them
furthermore if the lutes has even
managed to convince her by showing her
other realities or by predicting the
future then this ruins part of the main
game's story as booker could have easily
just told her that he was from a
different timeline and not an imposter
which could have stopped all the people
we killed that were a part of the vox
it's never explained what ultimately
convinced her so the team is once again
able to get away with this vague scene
changing the story by giving away very
little information that a was never
hinted at and b should have never even
happened is not good storytelling and
also in an effort to clown this scene
again because i think it's funny all
they said was to take the boy hostage
nothing about the blood wiping so once
again i have to ask what the point was
eventually elizabeth will grab the blue
test particle but tsujong won't let her
leave until she gets him hair of the
test subject that was bonded to songbird
which is quite funny as he is literally
talking to that test subject the hair
sample is located in fink's office and
is a really nice location as we get to
see all the tests that he ran trying to
get songbirds to connect with elizabeth
it's also pretty horrifying that deps he
was willing to go to to do something
like this like hooking up an animal to a
mask that would constantly pump oxytocin
into their lungs as well as the other
failed test subjects still in the
laboratory elizabeth then grabs the hair
sample and delivers it to sung via numo
tube and i don't think it's ever
explained in this game but shouldn't the
numo tubes be connected i can't imagine
that the two packages the item and
floats it across the water so how does
this get from point a to point b when
fontaine died ryan forced su chong to
work for him and that's why his new lab
was at the artemis suites far away from
this department store plus the store is
thousands of meters below rapture since
ryan sunken so is the pneumotube still
connected to the other tube or was there
never a tube in the first place it's not
a huge concern just something i noticed
after delivering the hair ryan appears
on the intercom and attempts to kill us
we escape his thugs make it to the
desired location use the loot test
particle to float the department store
back up to rapture and then get knocked
out by atlas's men after this the story
goes back to the roots of bioshock 1 as
atlas wants us to look for the ace in
the hole who of course is jack and while
i was very excited to see jack in some
fashion i don't even really think this
was necessary in the over 10 years since
i played the first bioshock game not
once did i wonder how atlas got jack i
think it's more important that he got
jack at all more than how he got him
there's also a myriad of ways you could
have explained that he got him to
rapture this is going to be a bit bold
of me but i'd like to rewrite this
episode in a way that would make more
sense at least to me firstly remove any
mention of atlas up until this point
allow elizabeth to get up and question
how she is alive along with booker it'll
draw more attention to how elizabeth
ended episode 1 standing and is now
starting this episode on the ground
maybe even add some blood as well to
show that she didn't pass out but was
actually injured with atlas in the
picture all i could care about was him i
didn't even bother questioning how
booker even got here the way booker's
written into this episode is totally
fine i'm actually okay with him just
being a figment of her imagination the
rest of the episode should be spent
trying to find sally and then this would
be a good time to have sally also be
held by sue chong since it'll force
elizabeth to go to colombia and get her
hair in exchange for sally this however
though does involve the lutest particle
and colombia something i'd prefer to
avoid in this episode so maybe we can
have some joke scene where elizabeth
reveals to sue chong that she is in fact
the test subject and then maybe have soo
chong freak out and get a little angry
at the fact the solution to his issue
was literally right in front of him and
seeing as he's in rapture and not the
department store this could make su
chong be the sole reason the sword was
lifted as he needs her hair this not
only connects the following scene with
andrew ryan where he says that the deal
between su chong and elizabeth was not
one he was authorized to make but this
also fits narratively with su chong as a
character who not only worked with
fontaine before he died and could maybe
discover the real identity of atlas but
also show that he is still a person
willing to do anything to get what he
wants once elizabeth makes it to sue
chong she can then drop off her hair and
then right when she meets sally she gets
knocked out by some thugs which leads to
the scene right here once this starts
have the bag stay on elizabeth's head
but have atlas talk to his crew while
we're here it sets up atlas but also
lets the veteran players get excited as
his accent is very recognizable they
could even change the name to man
instead of atlas in the subtitles
momentarily so that the reveal isn't
spoiled then when the hype of his
appearance is still high rip the bag off
and show him even keeping this part
where the light blocks his face but then
reveals him as he steps closer would
have also worked as well personally i
would have preferred this dlc to
continue its own story and have atlus be
revealed in the last few moments since
atlas is now a main character in this
episode from the start it takes all
focus off everyone else as he's easily
the most important character in this
episode doing this would also remove the
questionable decisions that elizabeth
makes throughout this dlc as from the
moment she meets with him she knows that
she'll betray him and it ruins all the
build up when it's not only hammered in
multiple times that atlas will likely
betray her but also the fact that
elizabeth keeps helping him despite
knowing she won't get the upper hand on
him as we discover at the end the reason
she's doing this is because within all
the doors there was a timeline that
shows sally having a future thanks to
jack rescuing her but to do this she
needs to go along with the events of the
story in order to make this all happen
which not only undermines all the power
and skill atlas has as a leader but also
makes the reveal of how atlas got his
hands on jack just really awkward
furthermore the only reason she was able
to do any of this was because of booker
who reminds her that she used to see all
the doors meaning she has all the
memories of all the doors regardless of
whether it was the past present or
future so booker tries to get her to
remember where the location of the ace
and the hole is this confirmed a
suspicion i had and that was that booker
was placed in this episode strictly to
explain plots and discoveries the
writers couldn't explain on their own
and this makes everything feel so forced
just have booker stay a memory her
memory of booker the booker who she grew
to love and appreciate and have him be
the shoulder she can cry on they are
father and daughter after all don't add
this current booker that is helping
discover the next step in the story
because elizabeth can't remember or is
incapable of making a decision it just
feels like such a waste to have the
story the way it is now and it goes back
to what i said earlier as it answers a
question we didn't even really need
answered the best thing to come from
this part though was the interrogation
scene which makes me extremely
uncomfortable where's me ace in the hole
i don't
know
what else rests in the lobe
creativity
individuality
and personality
in short
what makes you
you continuing with the story though
elizabeth needs to get to su chong's
clinic in order to find info on jack she
then finds the paper that has the would
you kindly pass phrase and then gives it
to atlas during this level we do get to
see how su chong died rather than
hearing it and while cool the story is
doing that thing again where it's trying
to fit elizabeth into the plot by having
her be the sole reason behind all these
events she was the reason that the big
daddies could bond to any little sister
she was then responsible for su chong's
death and is of course responsible for
the events of the whole series since she
gave atlas the passphrase for jack it's
completely unnecessary to do all of this
and i have no idea why they thought this
was a good idea also unless i'm mistaken
i'm pretty sure the bonding process was
created using pheromones of the big
daddies combined with the mental
conditioning that the little sisters
underwent we use the pheromones
ourselves in bioshock 1 and we get to
see the little sisters minds in bioshock
too so this whole scene is confusing as
it implies that just a little bit of
atom was all that was needed even though
it's known that the big daddies were
spliced beyond belief to even get them
to function in the suits so they already
have atom in them plus the atom the
little sisters have is probably recycled
you could claim that the little sisters
have unique atoms since their bodies do
contain the sea slug that produces it
but we can see them drinking atom on
occasion in game thus it's recycled
anyway so this is just confusing for no
reason elizabeth has such a vital role
in her own reality but they needed to
make her have the same role in the
rapture reality but it was just
unnecessary now instead of saying that
the addiction of adam the feud between
fontaine and ryan and the values of
rapture were all contributing factors to
not only the downfall of rapture but the
events of the game it can now just be
boiled down to elizabeth did it to help
sally it ruins years of work and that is
extremely upsetting after elizabeth gets
the passphrase she gives it to atlas as
she has to sensibly to sally being
rescued to which she receives a wrench
to the head for her assistance we then
get a slideshow of the events that took
place in bioshock 1 and see that her
vision became a reality as sally is
rescued by jack and given a future as
she comes back to reality we can see her
holding sally while elizabeth eventually
succumbs to her wounds and dies thus
ending the dlc burial at sea wasn't
terrible but it definitely wasn't great
either it's a dlc that probably didn't
need to exist but i would have accepted
its existence if it didn't fumble so
hard in the second episode the dlc not
only has a few retcons and plot holes
but also undermines all the story and
world building the original game set out
to create by pinning all the events on
one character a character that shouldn't
have even had this vital of a role in
the first place and arguably shouldn't
have even been here anyway infinite was
made to be different and a separation
from the series and while i didn't
appreciate it that much as i've said
before i will at least commend them for
sticking to their original vision and
trying to create something new despite
that they still couldn't get away from
rapture and thus needed to go back was
it great to see rapture in its prime as
well as the original cast of characters
absolutely but the rest of the dlc
soured any enjoyment that i had from it
bioshock infinite as a whole is a
surreal experience it's got a compelling
story with a wonderful twist and a great
dynamic between the two main characters
and even a decent setup to a dlc in
episode 1 culminating in a good game but
it also has a lack of interesting audio
logs bland gameplay repetitive locations
and an abysmal second episode that ruins
the grey parts infinite established
tearing it down in the process had
infinite just ended at the main game i
would have called it great or even
fantastic but burial at sea went too far
it's said that the series had ended on
such a conflicting note like this where
people are more than likely to argue
whether or not the game was even good to
begin with rather than just appreciating
how far the series has come infinite
leaves a permanent stain on this series
fantastic legacy and that's truly what
upsets me the most
despite bioshock infinite being the
final game in the series we still have
more bioshock to talk about as
throughout the game's life cycle two
books were written bioshock rapture and
bioshock mind and revolt now both of
these books are not comics so this won't
be the most visually entertaining
section but i will try to provide
footage of the characters and locations
mentioned so if a book happens to
mention finkton for example then i'll
put some thinked in gameplay on screen
as well as any characters that are
mentioned as well also because of some
possible copyright concerns i won't be
talking about every detail and thus will
only be summarizing the important parts
hopefully though it will be enough to
get you a general understanding of the
material so that you can come to a
decision on whether or not you should
read it yourself so firstly let's get
the easy one out of the way bioshock
mind and revolt is a 30 page ebook
written by joe fielder mind in revolt
was actually written in-house as joe
fielder was one of the writers for the
game so this story is separated into
different parts as the different
chapters are various interviews with
daisy fitzroy which are being conducted
by dr francis pinchot these chapters
aren't published in a professional
manner as they're just notes and
transcripts and we can see from the
forward and afterward of the book that
the person putting all these together is
a doctor pedophile the reason he has
decided to publish these interviews is
that he believes this will lead to a
better colombia however dr petafog is
rightfully worried about the outcome of
this publication as dr francis was
meeting with the city's most notorious
criminal and from what we'll see in the
notes he is indifferent about her as he
cares more about her mind rather than
her actions so some people may see him
as a traitor and refuse to see the
results of his work all these interviews
occurred over six days as our first
transcript is may 7 1909 and our last is
may 13 1909. that means the events of
bioshock infinite have yet to occur as
that was in 1912. the first question
though is how did dr francis meet with
daisy well according to the first
transcript daisy fitzroy was captured by
some authorities down in finton after
hearing this news he immediately
gathered all the paperwork necessary
that would allow him to interview her dr
francis believes that while the people
of colombia are objectively better than
the people down below referring to those
in the united states he thinks much can
be learned from these lesser people he
wants to see what makes these people
tick and hopes that discovering this
information could lead to treatment his
logic is definitely there but it's a bit
flawed as it seems like he wants to see
why people who don't conform to
colombia's ideals are the way that they
are in hopes of treating them to see the
beauty that colombia provides it's not
perfect but in terms of therapy he's
kind of on the right track before the
interview begins dr francis reads off a
list of her crimes which were included
but not limited to murder transportation
of firearms manufacturing of explosive
devices and the printing of material
that promoted unionization public
assembly and the general undermining of
the colombian government that last crime
refers to her manifesto called the
people's voice which is a book we can
find in game although we aren't actually
allowed to read it even though we
already know this mind and revolt does
confirm that all of this started after
the death of lady comstock as we know
that father comstock killed her and then
blamed it on daisy as you would expect
she is very uncooperative in this
interview so dr francis takes the
opportunity to read some of the quotes
in the manifesto eventually daisy will
speak out and the two will get into an
argument as daisy sees dr francis like
everyone else in colombia as she says
when it comes down to it one snake is
the same as any other dr francis
attempts to reassure her that he merely
just wants to understand her and not
harm her so the following day he lets
daisy ask the first question the two
would then discuss how each arrived in
colombia and we learned that daisy along
with many other black mexican irish
chinese and jewish people were just
brought in during the dead of night many
were either convinced to come aboard due
to colombia waving their past crimes
some needed money to feed their families
and others were just taken from their
homes dr francis is quite shocked at the
revelation to hear that fink would
knowingly employ criminals and finds it
absurd this interview would be the first
of many times dr francis would hear
about the truth of colombia and will
eventually get to see how this affects
him later on after days of interviews dr
france's supervisor is becoming quite
unhappy regarding his results and
suggests that a change in strategy be
implemented he suggests that they
conduct a phrenology test which was
ultimately discredited years later and
has been the cause of many racist and
sexist claims such as certain races
being inferior to others due to the
shape of their brain and that women's
brains have larger sections for child
care and religion while they had smaller
sections for arts and sciences his
supervisor also recommends a new study
that they're conducting which would
eventually be called lobotomy neither of
these are something dr francis wants as
he claims that his style is vital to
colombia's growth more interviews will
continue and we can see dr francis
getting more and more annoyed at her
calling her responses blasphemous
eventually daisy will make a remark
towards the doctor which causes him to
slap her she laughs a bit after this
encounter as she's finally able to see
the real doctor as she claims wednesday
may 12th a few days before daisy will be
put under the supervisor's orders and
forced to be lobotomized was where the
shortest interview took place as dr
francis is reading back the results of
her iq test and discovered that daisy
scored a 149 which not only according to
the scoring means she is a genius in the
eyes of colombia but is also higher than
dr francis himself who scored a 146.
after seeing these results though he
will end the interview to think about
how to proceed next clearly he is
running out of time and his supervisor
is getting very annoyed at his lack of
progress in his private journal we can
read a transcript between the two of
them that occurred once he shut the
voxaphone off overall i don't mind how
this was handled but it did seem a bit
fast as one day there is no progress
then the next day she spills her entire
plan this is also the reason why writing
in this format can be very restrictive
as it's meant to mimic a compilation of
journal and recording entries so we
obviously won't hear any of this since
this was discussed after the recording
was turned off it makes sense in regards
to the format of the story it just feels
a bit out of nowhere and caused a bit of
whiplash while reading as for her plans
though she spoke about a plot to break
her out of jail and that if dr francis
is involved in her escape it will end in
little to no bloodshed this actually
changes dr francis's thoughts regarding
his work as while he is an upstanding
citizen of colombia doubts have started
to creep into his mind this made him
realize that sin exists in all men
regardless of their place in life as
while he thinks very highly of himself
and is void of such rebellious ideas to
discover that these thoughts were in his
mind was a bit shattering to him he
attempted to quell these thoughts within
him but realized intense transformation
would be required to do so such as
changing the current comstock center
from a research facility to a
re-education center but the thought of
torturing these patients with auditory
and visual stimuli that would ultimately
force them to conform to the proper
ideals of colombia is terrifying and
something he once again wants to avoid
the final day approaches and during
their final interview we can see that
daisy has the upper hand she's the one
controlling the interview while dr
francis is still consumed by the
thoughts of what he believes is right
for colombia but also what is right for
himself eventually a break-in occurs and
dr francis decides that he will end up
helping daisy and gives her a set of
keys that will not only unlock some of
the facility's doors but also herself
she meets up with some of her men and
thanks the doctor for helping her escape
but before leaving gives him a pardon
gift which is a bullet through his head
her final line before killing dr francis
is it ain't a matter of have to it's a
matter of want it seems that despite how
honest dr francis was with his
intentions regarding their interview
daisy refused to believe him and only
saw him as a pawn in her game honestly
this was quite a sad story as dr francis
albeit still stuck in his ways was at
least willing to learn from daisy which
is something not many people in colombia
would even try to do to end the
publication we have an afterword from dr
petafog who explains that despite dr
franz's interest in daisy the blame is
not entirely his own as the betrayal of
the mind can happen to anyone even the
great citizens of colombia and it was
thanks to his bravery and research that
they were able to come up with an array
of treatment methods which will be
hosted at the all-new
comstock re-education center dr
francis's worst thoughts had come to
life the facility turned towards more
forceful methods of change and we can
see this in game as the comstock house
level is the re-education center we can
see the numerous slideshows of
phrenology and lobotomy as well as the
results they had on the patients it's a
truly horrific site my gender vault was
a short but sweet story it's not a
necessary read as it only discussed one
instance than the colombian timeline
that ultimately wasn't too important but
for three dollars on amazon it was
definitely worth the price so if you're
interested in a bit of the thoughts on
daisy fitzroy then i recommend you pick
this up our final book is bioshock
rapture an over 400 page novel that
details some of the events prior to the
first bioshock game as opposed to the
previous book that was written in-house
this was written by a third-party author
named john shirley however the project
was overseen by game director ken levine
and according to some tweets and
interviews regarding the book he also
got to write the epilogue and prologue
while jon surely handled the rest to
some of you that name may sound familiar
as while he does produce some books of
his own he was also contracted to write
many books for other games such as halo
watch dogs and borderlands so before
things begin we can read a prologue that
takes place before raptor's creation and
it gives us a look into why it was
created the two characters in the
prologue are andrew ryan and sullivan
sullivan was a security officer for ryan
which is how the two met he came into
ryan's office to give him the reports he
asked for and was displeased with both
of them one was about the ongoing union
strikes and how many companies workers
were fighting for better rights ryan
believes these workers to be soviet
agents as russia was going under similar
strikes at the same time he finds it
absurd that they want better wages in
working conditions as he claims that
this is the basis of socialism something
ryan is definitely not fond of the final
report was the nail in the coffin for
ryan he received reports of what
occurred in japan during world war ii
the report not only had pictures of the
bombings with the effects they had on
some of the citizens that survived he
realized that the world was spiraling
into chaos and with nuclear weapons
being created an all-out atomic war
would be inevitable so ryan set his
plans in motion he plans to make a place
untouched by the government where people
live away from rules and regulations we
of course know this to be rapture before
the prologue ends we get a backstory of
ryan's escape from russia we also get to
learn his full name which i don't recall
ever being stated in the games before
but it is andrei ranowski his backstory
goes into grave detail about the world
that andrew ryan saw with his eyes
saying things like the dawn sky the
colors of a deep bruise and the cutting
winds serrated by sleet the problem with
books is the lack of a visual which is
why they tend to go into detail about
the surroundings to give the reader an
idea of what to imagine and i'm glad
this style wasn't lost when making this
book however there is a minor
inconsistency as the book states he fled
russia in 1918 when in fact in game it
was 1919 not a huge deal but something i
just wanted to mention part one of the
book covers chapters one through five
and it's all about the building of
rapture we also get to meet our
protagonist bill mcdonough bill was
contracted to help fix something at the
building that ryan owned which is how
the two met we also learned that the
reason andrew ryan is so rich is that he
owns a significant amount of oil and
coal on top of owning the second biggest
railroad in the country details like
this occur throughout the whole book and
it's definitely something i took a
liking to at the end of the day it's not
important how ryan got his money just
that he had the money to build rapture
but the book wanted to add these details
to piece together the small holes left
by the game it's the details that'll
make you say oh so that's how that
happened or that's why this occurred and
the book manages to excel at this
something else i noticed was the use of
audio logs from the games as on page 30
bill is currently fixing ryan's toilet
and when ryan sees his work he asks
about the type of fitting claiming that
the other guys are using tin while bill
is using brass this is taken directly
from an audio log in game wait says it
what's with all the brass fittings
general contractor had me down for the
tin
well i says
i suppose it's the contractor then it
will be bailing out your low once a
fortnight is it if it's price you're
worried about i'll be picking up the
brass so not to worry squad this small
inclusion made me feel a lot more
comfortable when reading as the story
and its additional material were taken
into consideration it sounds like the
bare minimum when it comes to writing a
book for a game but i appreciated it
nonetheless the rest of the part
switches between bill mcdonough and a
frank gorlund frank gorland is a simple
bartender that likes to fudge games of
boxing to make a quick buck and also
likes to use the bar as a way to gain
information some of this information he
received was on the project that andrew
ryan was working on and he figured that
if he could get involved in this project
he could take it from under his nose if
that sounds like someone specific then
you would be right is by the end of the
part we discover that frank gorland is
actually frank fontaine his chapters
were excellent as they showed the
lengths he's willing to go to get what
he wants and also displayed his skill at
creating different identities and
personalities as he switches quite a lot
throughout the park by the end of part
one he is close to finding out ryan's
plan but he hasn't found out where the
project is as for bill mcdonough he's
made quite the impression on injurine
and has been promoted to the lead
contractor for the building of rapture
ryan took bill on a trip to visit some
of his friends these friends of course
being jasmine jolene and sander cohen
sander cohen was used in this part as a
way for ryan to show bill how some of
these people are constrained by the
world and hopes to create a society that
doesn't need to worry about these
constraints eventually ryan and bill
will leave and take a trip to iceland to
which a boat will be waiting to take
them to the building site of rapture
ryan also shows bill a small model of
the city and what he plans to have it
look like he also explains how arcadia
works which is something i did not
expect to read as according to ryan
arcadia has a system that brings in
reflected sunlight as well as electrical
light then this will be used by the
trees which will eventually lead to them
producing oxygen once again a detail
that ties in some of the questions left
untouched by the game the final pages of
the part are bill ryan and many of the
other contractors staring at awe at the
foundation of rapture knowing that in
time a new wonder of the world will be
created part 2 is chapters 6 through 15
and this chapter tends to skip around a
bit as we get to see many different
characters take center stage for a bit
all while jumping around in the timeline
as we go from 1949 to 1953 within just a
couple dozen pages these chapters are
here to add more substance to the story
by giving context to future events
providing more backstory on the game via
audio logs or just small conversations
that flesh out the world for example
there's a more detailed look at julie
lankford's audio log where she's upset
that ryan's turning her arcadia guarded
into a paid attraction but then a few
pages later there's a quick scene
between sophia lamb and a patient furs
that gets interrupted momentarily when
eleanor comes into the room since this
part spans many years in the rapture
timeline lots of progress has been made
and many people are flocking to the
underwater city in hopes of striking it
big we also get to see lots of the games
cast in this part as many of the main
and side characters from both games are
given center stage think of it as a
anthology of sorts as every few pages
the story pivots to another scene and
since they're so far apart from one
another most of the short stories don't
contradict or overlap i really liked
being able to see all the characters in
these new situations as they all have
these unique reactions to everything
going on not just in rapture but in the
moment like this one part where
tenenbaum and tsu chong are trying to
perform a pregnancy examination and it's
hilarious hearing them talk about this
child like it's a test subject and
conversating about their experiences in
examinating children while completely
ignoring the fact that this woman
they're testing on is crying out in
extreme pain but while most of this part
is broken up into small stories there is
some important developments happening
within them as we start to see the
beginning of sofia lam and her family
via the free therapy sessions as well as
the discovery and creation of adam we
also get to read about some of the more
depressing events that transpire in
rapture like all the people who feel
trapped and alone as they can't leave
rapture due to ryan's orders or how
someone screwed over another man's
business which eventually led to a
dispute and a shootout i like that this
book was able to convey to the reader
that rapture wasn't a complete utopia we
already knew this from the games but we
only understood that things became
problematic after rapture was up and
running but things are going wrong and
it's not even finished yet towards the
end of the part is where we get to the
real meat of the story as splicers are
introduced fontaine and ryan are
attempting to take each other down and
people are irritated about the living
conditions things haven't fully gone to
[ __ ] yet as the bombing in 1958 is still
a couple years away but it's very clear
that rapture is starting to crack the
book is slowly but truly giving us all
the different events of rapture that
would eventually lead to its downfall
part two is by far the longest part
taking up around half the book and it is
by far my favorite part as there is tons
of references to past locations and
characters that allow us to take what we
already know about them and apply to
these pages i found myself remembering
all their backstories when all the
characters appeared and tried to take
that into consideration when they were
relevant to the scene while this part
was initially all over the place and
sometimes a bit hard to organize when
taking into account the full timeline it
ultimately doesn't matter as once again
most of these stories aren't relevant to
one another and are spread far apart
enough that they won't contradict or
overlap but as the part reached the end
it started injecting familiar material
that fans of the games would remember
along with a cohesive story that would
set up the final part part 3 is chapters
15 through 20 and is very similar to the
end of part 2 in the sense that there
are sporadic stories that may jump ahead
a few months or a year but they all
connect on this very thin timeline that
make up the actual story this part not
only has a few pages dedicated to
providing background on events we
already know of but also allow us to see
many events that were briefly talked
about in the games for example the raid
on fontaine futuristics that would
eventually lead to the fake death of
fontaine and the creation of atlas as
well as the bombing on new year's eve
were all mentioned and we're not only
able to see the events happen but also
the aftermath of said events we were
also able to get an in-depth look on the
conversation between fontaine souchong
and tenenbaum regarding the mental
conditioning of jack and how they were
going to steal ryan's child and even the
doubts that tenenbaum would have
throughout the story that would
eventually lead to how we see her in
game as she has a change of heart about
the little sisters these were fantastic
to read about and i was so excited to
see how all of this fit into the story
however not all of these events had the
same feeling there's a few
inconsistencies in this part as well we
talked about one before regarding the
year ryan left russia but there's also a
few more in these later chapters the
book never mentions any discoveries of
tares within rapture which we know did
exist at some point thanks to burial at
sea however this book was written in
2011 a few years before burial at sea
was even released so i'm willing to
overlook this simply because the game
was still in development however one i
won't forgive is jasmine's death as we
know in fort frolick sandra cohen wants
us to kill some of his associates so we
can display their picture on his art
project to kill one of them we need to
go into the room where jasmine was
killed so that we can get him to spawn
in the bar behind us in this room is
jasmine's body along with a bloody
weapon implying she was beat to death we
also hear some of the conversation
thanks to some of the ghostly
apparitions that occur throughout the
game so it's clear that she was killed
with a weapon but according to the book
ryan strangled her to death now you
could make the argument that he
strangled her then hit her with a blunt
object but the book never mentions
anything about a weapon so it leads me
to believe that they had incorrectly
added this what bothers me the most is
that this is a required and integral
part of the story and was somehow missed
despite this being overlooked by game
director ken levine as well as all the
other writers and designers that shirley
was in contact with i can see some small
detail being left out that was maybe
mentioned once in a random audio log but
for something such as this that is not
only one of the most important parts of
bioshock's story but is also required to
watch if you want to complete the game
is baffling how this was incorrect as we
go through the final pages everything is
turning into the rapture we know from
the games raids for food are happening
all the time ryan is losing influence
and the little sisters are patrolling
the hallways for adam at the end diane
mcclintlock who you'll remember from
bioshock 1 as ryan's love interest for a
time and also the one who recorded that
bombing during new year's eve ends up
joining atlas and betraying ryan until
she accidentally discovers that atlas is
fontaine and even though she would have
definitely kept his secret atlas
couldn't take the chance and stabs her
letting her bleed out on the floor this
is just like the other events we talked
about before as this was literally from
an audio log in game but now we get to
see the full story behind it as for our
protagonist if we remember from an audio
log in the game we know that he was
going to kill ryan if he had to and when
bill his wife eileen and his daughter
sophie attempt to escape rapture he
realizes what needs to be done he points
his gun at ryan but he couldn't do it
ryan gave him this job and allowed him
to create his city and it's because of
his generosity that he couldn't pull the
trigger ryan takes the opportunity to
fight back smacking bill in the head
with his cane and while bill maintains
the upper hand by bashing him with his
gun he once again couldn't finish the
job he wishes andrew ryan good luck and
leaves his office the family along with
bill's friend roland wallace make it to
the bathyspheres and take it all the way
back up to the lighthouse but they're
caught by ryan's guards these guards are
karlowski redgrave and candivish names
you won't be familiar with but were
quite frequent throughout the book and
are friends of bill everyone is arguing
over what to do as bill and his family
want to leave but the guards won't let
him everyone has also split in regards
to bill's family as while the order was
just for roland and bill there was
nothing about his wife and child
eventually an argument would break out
between the three guards that left one
dead redgrave and karlowski take bill
and wallace back to rapture but allow
his wife and child to leave as for their
fates roland wallace became a test
subject for sue chong and was subjected
to the enraged plasmid which we can hear
the results of from an audio log in
bioshock 1 and bill is executed for his
crimes we could see bill's body in game
and it shows that he was crucified but
according to the book since redgrave and
karlovsky liked bill they opted to kill
him first as to not let him suffer even
though bill's capture was ryan's order
andrew ryan didn't come to the execution
showing that even though he was a
traitor he was ultimately losing a dear
friend and couldn't see him die i loved
the relationship these two had
throughout the book as through bill's
eyes were able to see this different
andrew ryan one that had a bit more
compassion and more drive the final
pages are about bill's family who are
now on the surface his daughter was
diagnosed with agoraphobia thanks to
rapture and while a bit better off
eileen is still suffering from
everything that occurred the last line
is the two talking about how bill would
have loved to see the surface again
bioshock rapture was fantastic i've
always been a visual learner which is
why i prefer manga over books like this
but i can't deny that for only ten
dollars this was a genuinely great read
and that goes for mind and revolt as
well i highly recommend both books if
you have the time and money for them if
you're interested in a bit of the
backstory regarding daisy fitzroy then
mind and revolt will be a short but
sweet read as for bioshock rapture i
think if you enjoy rapture even just a
little bit you will love this book the
constant callbacks to past events and
characters as well as its ability to
fill in some of the gaps left by the
story was more than enough to give it my
recommendation
with all the games and books discussed i
could finally say that we have reached
the end of bioshock despite the
criticism that i gave i would ultimately
recommend everything discussed in this
video that goes for both the books and
games while some are better than others
each one has at least something that
makes the game worth playing whether
that's the setting characters or world
building each game excels at something
it is without a doubt one of the best
series ever made and i can't thank you
enough for allowing me to talk about
them one more time but even though i
said this was the end apparently it's
not as netflix has announced a bioshock
movie and i guess a fourth game is in
production there is very little
information surrounding these additions
to the series but i will attempt to
remain hopeful video game movies and
shows are either amazing or terrible and
while i'm always willing to give it a
try i'd be lying if i said i wasn't
worried i think a good setting for the
movie would definitely be pre-civil war
rapture but that would inevitably run
into issues with the book so continuity
and canon discussion will probably occur
as for the game apparently on a podcast
called the sacred symbols the host
claims that the game will take place in
a 1960 city in antarctica called
borealis admittedly that does sound
quite interesting but what's more
worrying is the story surrounding the
game this is around the same time as
bioshock 1. and while it is far away
from rapture are they just going to move
away from it all together or will the
team make reference to it i feel like it
could be possible if this could work as
long as they don't mention anyone from
the current trilogy it would suck but if
they start adding characters we're
familiar with then we'll have to take
the other games into account which will
probably result in a really messy story
regardless if any of these projects are
actually released expect me to talk
about them when they do for the final
time though thank you all for joining me
on this journey through the bioshock
series and i hope you enjoyed if you did
be sure to leave a like and subscribe if
you're new we have a ton more games i'd
love to cover so if this style of videos
is interesting to you then i hope you
stick around for more as always thank
you to my returning viewers for coming
back to another video and with that take
care everyone
and goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]